foreign
web services have become a Mainstay in
the web hosting industry thanks to the
reliability speed and relatively trouble
free management
the pricing structure that caters to
businesses of all sizes and industries
nearly half of the internet relies on
Amazon servers for some reason or other
consequently the market demand for AWS
solution Architects has grown
exponentially and still expect for the
increments
a few services are still used
extensively and AWS instances with
changing time let's take a look at the
topics to be covered today in a full
course on the top five AWS services to
master in 2022.
start by taking a look at AWS from a
beginner's perspective
we then cover a crucial part of AWS the
S3 bucket component
the next topic will explain how objects
and buckets find use in an S3 component
on AWS
next we take a look at what is an ec2
instance on Amazon AWS and also learn
how to create the aforementioned
instances and Link them with S3 buckets
to a data storage on Amazon web services
servers
the next will be covered in the video
will be AWS Lambda will cover its
mechanisms and the features using which
it backs up data on AWS servers and
facilitates easy restore functionalities
but then learn about AWS crowdfund
content delivery and Amazon virtual
private clouds
finally we cover some preset interview
questions people may come up against an
interviewing for roles like AWS solution
architect
meet Rob he runs an online shopping
portal the portal started with a modest
number of users but has recently been
seeing a surge in the number of visitors
on Black Friday and other holidays the
portal saw so many visitors that the
servers were unable to handle the
traffic and crashed is there a way to
improve performance without having to
invest in a new server wondered rob a
way to upscale or downscale capacity
depending on the number of users
visiting the website at any given point
well there is Amazon web services one of
the leaders in the cloud computing
Market before we see how AWS can solve
Rob's problem let's have a look at how
AWS reached the position it is at now
AWS was first introduced in 2002 as a
means to provide tools and services to
developers to incorporate features of
amazon.com to their website in 2006 its
first Cloud Services offering was
introduced in 2016 AWS surpassed its 10
billion Revenue Target
and now AWS offers more than 100 cloud
services that span a wide range of
domains thanks to this the AWS cloud
service platform is now used by more
than 45 percent of the global market now
let's talk about what is AWS AWS or
Amazon web service is a secure cloud
computing platform that provides
computing power database networking
content storage and much more the
platform also works with a PSU go
pricing model which means you only pay
for how much of the service is offered
by AWS you use
some of the other advantages of AWS are
security AWS provides a secure and
durable platform that offers end-to-end
privacy and security
experience you can benefit from the
infrastructure management practices born
from Amazon's years of experience
flexible it allows users to select the
OS language database and other services
easy to use users can host applications
quickly and securely
scalable depending on user requirements
applications can be scaled up or down
AWS provides a wide range of services
across various domains
what if Rob wanted to create an
application for his online portal AWS
provides compute services that can
support the app development process from
start to finish from developing
deploying running to scaling the
application up or down based on the
requirements
the popular Services include ec2 AWS
Lambda Amazon light cell and elastic
Beanstalk for storing website data Rob
could use AWS storage services that
would enable him to store access govern
and analyze data to ensure that costs
are reduced agility is improved and
Innovation accelerated
popular services within this domain
include Amazon S3 EBS S3 Glacier and
elastic file storage
Rob can also store the user data in a
database with aw Services which he can
then optimize and manage popular
services in this domain include Amazon
RDS dynamodb and redshift if Rob's
businesses took off and he wanted to
separate his Cloud infrastructure or
scale up his work requests and much more
he would be able to do so with the
networking Services provided by AWS some
of the popular networking Services
include Amazon VPC Amazon Route 53 and
elastic load balancing other domains
that AWS provide services in are
analytics blockchain containers machine
learning internet of things and so on
and there you go that's AWS for you in a
nutshell now before we're done let's
have a look at a quiz which of these
services are incorrectly matched one
two
[Music]
three
four
we'll be pinning the question in the
comment section comment below with your
answer and stand a chance to win an
Amazon voucher several companies around
the world have found great success with
AWS companies like Netflix twitch
LinkedIn Facebook and BBC have taken
advantage of the services offered by AWS
to improve their business efficiency
it's AWS S3 tutorial for beginners my
name is Kent and today I'm going to be
covering these following points I'm
going to be covering what is cloud
computing I'm going to be showcasing
what AWS is in terms of cloud computing
and I'm also going to be covering the
core fundamental service of the simple
storage service which is a object
storage service we're going to be
covering the benefits of the simple
storage service better known as S3 what
objects and buckets are and we're going
to be seeing how things are working in
the background and implementing that in
terms of
lab assisted demonstrations in order for
you to see what those features of S3 are
and then we'll perform a wrap up of the
material we've done in a conclusion so
let's get started what is cloud
computing
so here is a definition of cloud
computing but I'm going to paraphrase it
cloud computing is nothing more than you
gaining access to infrastructure
through web services with a
pay-as-you-go model now this is a very
very different model than where
traditionally
involved in on a on-prem data center so
when I mean on-prem I'm saying on
premise okay so you'll hear that a lot
on-prem now when we are on on-premise
data center we have to provision lots of
infrastructure even before we get
started with
deploying any type of application
whether it would be a mobile application
a web application etc etc
so every application needs some sort of
underlying infrastructure whether that
be bare bone servers databases they're
obviously going to be needing some types
of storage
etc etc so all this is something that we
have to kind of fight against in order
just to get started with deploying our
application so this takes usually
traditionally depending on the size of
the company about three months to set up
so what if we could Leverage
all this infrastructure
as a service and just through some API
call that's what the web services is all
about we could provision a server or we
could provision a database within
minutes and then deploy any type of
application that we want to on top of
that stack and also take advantage of
any storage that we may want we may want
object level storage which is what we're
going to cover we may want an elastic
file system right so there are different
types of storages that were eventually
going to look at as you go down your
learning path with simply learn so cloud
computing is really about provisioning
of all these kinds of services but not
only at the infrastructure level we're
going to see how we could move up the
stack and get entire platforms as a
service or even softwares as a service
so what is AWS
while AWS is really a cloud computing
platform that will offer us many many
services through these API calls some
are again just bare infrastructure like
a service other can be a service as a
software for example email so here we
have an example
of the public data storage this is S3
the simple storage service icon that
you're going to see over and over again
this is a representation of an actual
bucket in S3 so this will become more
clear as we continue the slide deck and
actually reinforce this with some
Hands-On lab but as you can imagine you
may want to provision a
private software-defined Network in the
cloud and so we can do that in AWS we
can provide load balancing we could
provide scalability in terms of Auto
scaling groups that will respond to
increased demand as your application
let's say
becomes more popular you want that
infrastructure to grow elastically so
doing this on premise is traditionally
not only extremely expensive and thus
prohibitive but very difficult to
implement physically speaking as well
so by going with a cloud provider like
AWS we can severely reduce the expense
and the complexity of setting all of
this up because
we're trading Capital expense for
variable expense so Capital expense is
about you procurring all the hardware
that you need beforehand and the budget
being approved before even getting that
Hardware in through your door right and
then you have to configure it so there's
that complexity Factor
whereas if you're doing this through AWS
you can within minutes
just provision all of that very quickly
so you're also not paying for everything
all up front you're paying this with a
pay as you go model so very different we
are now removing what's called
undifferentiated lifting which is
everybody has to do the same thing but
it's not really bringing any value to
their end product we all have to buy
servers and configure them and scale
them etc etc so if we remove that
element and have AWS handle that we can
concentrate on our business which is our
application and improving that
application
and responding more to our clients
request can be more agile more flexible
so all of this leads to these points
that we see here on this slide much
easier to use much easier to get our
application to Market we're actually
going to be leveraging the physical
security that AWS implements for us they
have data centers all over the world
that we're going to plug into and that
physical security is already implemented
for us there are varying levels of
security that we're going to get into
through our AWS Journey but right off
the bat you know that you have physical
security of course we're going to be
talking about storage in this
demonstration or in this slide deck over
here but the nice thing is is we only
pay for what we use so that's that
variable expense that I was talking
about that we've traded for Capital
expense we can easily set up databases
we can easily automate our backups and
have those backups stored
in the cloud through that S3 storage
that we're going to get into okay so
lots of benefits of going through AWS
here
and it's also comprehensive and simple
to use
comprehensive meaning that there are
hundreds and hundreds of services
it's going to be actually quite time
consuming for you to just know what each
service does in general but you'll get
there through your journey it's all
about sticking with it and learning
something new every day which is what
simple learn is all about
um over here we have infrastructure as a
service platform as a service and
software as a service so these are three
different types of distinctions we have
in the cloud industry to basically
cover what's going on here on the right
hand side so on premise you're
traditionally involved in everything
from networking which is you for example
buying the switches the routers the
cabling everything all the way up the
stock to deploying your application and
you see everything in between there okay
so this is a very time consuming job not
only that but it costs a lot of money
because you have to buy all these
machines up front and you have to have
the individuals with the right knowledge
to maintain all of this stack all right
so different individuals and different
teams maintaining this whole on-premise
data center you may also have different
data centers deployed globally so you
can imagine the cost overhead of this
so everything in green is basically
you're managing it now we can offset
that and ask AWS to handle part of this
stack over here so
on this second Point column over here we
see infrastructure as a service which
basically says AWS I want you to handle
all the networking my software-defined
network I want you to handle my storage
elasticity I want you to handle my
compute power my virtual machines I want
you to handle even
uh administrating those machines at a
physical layer as well and I want you to
physically secure them so this will
allow you more time to focus on all the
green up here
of course we can move up the stack and
say I even want AWS to take on more
responsibility
and that would be more of a platform as
a service where AWS would also install
and maintain the operating system for
you so you can imagine things like new
versions of operating systems security
patches maintenance patches all of the
like and any middleware or run time that
you have on top of that think of
something like the Java a virtual
machine perhaps that needs to be updated
now you wouldn't be
responsible for maintaining all of
what's in Orange over here you would
only be responsible for deploying your
application and making sure that your
data is saved and secured right so again
platform as a service is a more
hands-off approach so think of it as you
wanted to set up a CI CD deployment
environment
for your development team and you want
it to be very
involved in just handling your
application code and making sure that it
was properly
compiled built tested and deployed right
well this could be implemented as a
platform as a service or you could take
your code as a zip file and give it to
aws's
uh service called Beanstalk which would
automatically deploy your code and make
sure that it's highly available scalable
and fault tolerant across all of the
orange stack over here right so more of
a hands-off approach of course we can go
all the way up to stock and tell AWS to
take care of everything for us and just
ask for a service much like a utility
like electricity or water we might want
to say we just want an email software
service and we're not really concerned
about how the underlying operating
system or servers or network are
configured for that we just want to use
the software as a service we don't want
to administrate anything else we just
want to be sort of like an end user to
it so AWS will manage everything
underneath the hood so there are varying
types of services you pick and choose
whichever one makes more sense for you
and your team
so what is S3 S3 stands for simple
storage service and it is an object
storage service in Amazon what this
means is that it doesn't matter what
kind of file you upload to S3 it will be
treated as an abstraction meaning an
object so you can upload a PDF file you
can upload a JPEG file you can upload a
database backup it doesn't really matter
all that is abstracted Away by the use
of storing it within an object we're
going to talk more about what composes
an object but by doing so what happens
is S3 allows us to have
industry leading scalability so it
doesn't matter if you're going to make a
request for that database backup let's
say that object
five times or ten thousand times that
request that demand will scale the
underlying infrastructure that is
implemented behind the scenes is handled
for you so in a sense it's kind of like
a serverless service a storage service
where you're not implicated and handling
anything underneath the covers you're
just uploading your objects and
accessing them later on in terms of data
availability very powerful as well
because it takes those objects and will
replicate them across at least three
availability zones of course these
availability zones have one or more data
centers attached to them so you have
lots and lots of copies of your objects
distributed globally
or at least at a regional in a regional
area you can do this as well globally if
you enable global replication
and you will see that your level of your
availability will Skyrocket and you're
just not going to worry about losing an
S3 object
data security well we can encrypt our
data at rest or objects at rest we can
encrypt it in transit we can also come
up with security policies at the Bucket
Level which we're going to talk about
what a bucket is very very very soon
these are going to be implemented
through what's called I am policies and
you're going to be able to control who
or what has access to your objects
and of course because everything is
handled underneath the covers all the
servers all the storage nodes are Cloud
optimized for the best possible
performance
so let's continue on our journey on what
is S3 we're going to take a look at what
is a bucket and what is an object as you
can see here you have inside this bucket
which is a logical container for an
unlimited amount of objects you could
have objects of different shapes and
sizes like I said you could have
pictures database backups Etc so this is
what's being represented here by
different shapes
and you can think of a bucket really as
almost like a folder where objects or
files are placed within them
so there are many ways for us to place
objects within a bucket we can do this
through the AWS console which I'll be
showing you very shortly we can do this
via the command line interface or we can
do this to a software development kit at
the end of the day all those three
options go through an API right so it's
all about picking the right method that
is best suited for whatever kind of end
user or application that needs access to
these buckets and to these objects now
once you've got the data or objects
within this bucket
you can control pretty much how the data
is accessed how it's stored whether you
want it to be encrypted and how it's
even managed so you can have
organizations that have specific
compliance needs for example any objects
that are placed in or perhaps in PDFs
are not to be modified or not to be
touched for 90 days let's say we can
imply object locks if we want to we can
imply security guards we can also for
example record all API actions
that try to access to list to delete any
kind of API operations on those objects
at the Bucket Level or on the object
level we can record if that is some sort
of organizational compliance need for
auditing or for whatever internal
auditing reasoning that you may have
so continuing on here you can see that
there are many organizations that use S3
one and point is Amazon itself S3 is so
popular and so durable that Amazon
internally uses it to store its own data
you're guaranteed you know almost that
you're not going to lose any object in
there because it has what we call 11
nines durability now 11 9's durability
is really an extreme amount of
durability where it's mathematically
almost impossible for you to lose an
object once you've placed it in S3
you're in fact more liable to get hit by
a meteorite than you are to lose an
object in S3 statistically speaking
which is a pretty incredible statistic
but it's but it's true
so if we continue here with the benefits
of S3 some of these have already
described but let's talk about the full
picture here we see the performance
scalability availability and durability
of S3 are really you know first class in
the industry again durability we were
talking about that 11 9 silver that
really means is
99.99999 in total if you count all the
nines that's 11 of those nine so
um ex most durable in the industry by
far and again because everything is
handled underneath the covers it's a
serverless service they ensure the
scalability and availability and the
performance of
um the inner workings of that object
level storage now cost is of course
always important and S3 really shows up
here with first class support again for
cost it's got very very low cost can
have object level storage for let's say
a terabyte of object level storage for
as little as a dollar
a month so again it will depend on the
kind of storage class we're going to
have a discussion on different types of
storage classes that we might want to
transition or move over our objects for
one storage class to the next depending
on how frequently accessed that data is
as you know data over time seems to get
less and less accessed as you know your
needs shift from
one place to another we're going to talk
about that coming up very soon so we're
going to want to really focus on that to
reduce our end of the month costs for
storage with S3 of course security is
always at the Forefront and we want to
make sure that we either simply secure
by encrypting everything right off the
bat either at rest in transit or we want
to put an object lock or just maintain
security at the Bucket Level maintaining
let's say who or what has access to that
data because by default no one has
access to the data unless we open up the
door and also we want to make sure that
we don't give public access to our
bucket for obvious reasons of
giving away important information by
mistake so AWS makes it extremely
difficult for you to accidentally do
this and I'm going to show this in a
demonstration lab coming up very soon
and we can also query in place which is
very interesting so you can imagine you
putting let's say
a file that's in CSV format or a Json
format or parquet format some sort of
structured format or semi-structured
format in S3 and you can actually use
SQL queries on the spot to filter that
data in place at the Bucket Level you
could also have other services that may
want to extract some business
intelligence from that data in your S3
bucket directly as well so some other
more advanced querying operations can
take place at the S3 level so this you
will learn during your journey with
simply learn as you're covering all the
AWS technology stacks
and here the most widely used storage
cloud service in the industry because of
all the points that we just covered it
really is the number one storage or
object level storage solution in the
industry
let's now take a look at objects and
buckets in S3 so the objects are really
the fundamental entities that are stored
in S3 or the lowest common denominator
which means that we're not really
interested in what kind of data is
within the object at the layer of S3
because S3 doesn't have direct access to
the data within an object like I said
before it's an abstraction of the data
so we don't know if it's a cat's picture
if it's a backup of your database it's
just treated as a fundamental entity aka
the object now every object is
associated with metadata so data about
itself things like what's the name of
the object what's the size the time and
date that the object was uploaded things
of that nature are categorized
as metadata so S3 does have direct
access to that now the data within that
object of course is accessible by other
services so it's not that once you've
uploaded it you've totally lost the data
and it's only can be treated as an
object it's just that at this layer
it's simply just assigned metadata and a
version ID a unique version ID and if
you re-upload the exact same object the
second or third time to S3 it will have
its own version ID number so a new
unique version ID number will be
generated
so really what buckets are are there
logical containers to store those
objects so of course at an extremely
high level a bucket would be like your
root file system if you want to think
about it like that but that doesn't mean
you can't go into this bucket and create
separate folders now when you create
separate folders in a bucket because you
might want to logically organize all
your objects
you might be fooled by the fact that you
think this is a hierarchical storage
system when in fact it is not and I'll
talk about that in a second so you
cannot store an object without first
storing it into a bucket so of course
the first step would be for us to create
a bucket and then upload objects within
that bucket so an object cannot can
cannot exist without its container or
its bucket
so there's no windows explore view like
we're used to in an operating system
because this is not a hierarchical view
no matter if you create
folders within folders within folders in
fact S3's internal architecture is a
flat hierarchy
what we do instead is we assign prefixes
which are treated as folders in order to
logically organize our objects within
our buckets and I'm going to Showcase a
prefix in one of the demonstrations
coming up very soon
so when you create or when you're
working with S3 first of all you're
working at a regional level you're going
to have to pick a region for example you
might pick us East one region or USC's
two region and the bucket that you're
going to be creating will be replicated
across several availability zones but
within that region
also that data those objects can be
accessed globally because S3 uses the
HTTP protocol HTTP protocol is very
permissive everybody knows how to
administrate it and work with it so we
just need to give access to that object
in terms of a permission policy
and give it the proper
URL or give whoever needs access to the
proper URL and they can access that via
HTTP globally so first when you're
creating a bucket you have to select the
region and the object will live within
that region but that doesn't mean that
it still can't be accessed globally
so let's now take a minute go over to
the AWS console and actually let me
showcase how to create uh objects and
buckets
so for our first lab we're going to be
going and creating an S3 bucket and
uploading an object to it so we first
have to log into the AWS console which
we have up here in the address bar
let's click on either create free
account if it's your very first time or
as in is in my case I already have an
account and we're going to sign in here
you're gonna have to pass in your IM
username password and your account ID of
course
once you've logged in you can search for
the simple storage service S3 either by
coming up here in the search box and
typing S3 and you'll find it there
that's probably the easiest way or if
you want you can take a look at all the
services and it'll be under storage over
here the first one okay so pick
whichever method you see best for
yourself
once we're here we want to create
our first bucket
now I've already have a couple of
buckets here so we're going to go on and
create a new bucket the very first thing
is you have to specify a bucket name now
this bucket name has to be globally
unique if you take a look here at the
region that we're in it doesn't actually
select a specific region it selects the
global option which means that this
bucket will become globally accessible
so that is why it needs to have a unique
name much like a DNS name has to be
unique for your website right so I'm
going to come up here
and pick a name that I think is going to
be unique so I'm going to say simply
learn
S3 demo
all right let's take a look at if that's
going to work out of course we have to
pick a region but it is globally
accessible so you either pick a region
that's closest to your end users or in
our case since we're just doing a
demonstration we can do whichever is
closer to us right now okay and we're
going to skip these options for now
we're going to come back to them later
on we're just going to create
the bucket
now hopefully that was a unique name and
allowed me to create that and it looks
like it did so if I scroll down you can
see that it clearly got created over
here
now we're going to click on that and
we're going to start
uploading objects to this bucket
so let me click on the upload button
and you can either select one or more
files or you can select an entire folder
so I'm going to just go and select a
specific cat picture that I have here
okay and again we'll go through some of
those other options later on and we'll
just click upload
now this should take no time at all
because of the fact that's a very small
object or file that's being uploaded so
it is has succeeded we can close this up
and we see now clearly that the object
is in our bucket if we go to properties
we can see the metadata associated with
this bucket we can see the region that
it's in we can see the Arn which is the
Amazon resource name which uniquely
identifies this resource this bucket
across the globe so if ever you needed
to reference this let's say in an IM
policy or with other service needed to
communicate with S3 you would need this
Arn it's very important piece of
information and of course we have the
creation date some some high level
metadata so objects as we have covered
already consist of not only the data
itself but the metadata so there's lots
of metadata and there's a lot of other
features that we can go here and enable
very easily and this will be the basis
of the future demonstrations that I'm
going to do all right so just to recap
what we just did we created a unique
bucket
give it a name of
simply learn S3 demo and uploaded our
first object to it
so let's now take a look at the inner
workings of the Amazon S3
when we upload an object into a bucket
we have to select which one of these
storage classes the object will reside
in so you see I have six storage classes
here at the bottom and each have their
own characteristics that we're going to
get
into by default
if you don't specify anything it'll get
placed in What's called the S3 standard
storage class which is the most
expensive out of all these storage
classes
once your object gets colder and what I
mean by colder is your axis patterns
diminish meaning that you're accessing
that file less and less over the course
of time so it gets colder
you will transition that object from one
tier to the next all the way to for
example S3 deep archive so again deep
archive signifies extremely cold so
maybe you're only referencing this data
once a year once every couple of years
and so you want to have the cheapest
possible storage available so right now
you can get about one terabyte of
storage per month for about a dollar a
month with S3 Glacier deep archive so
you are going to be very interested in
knowing how to transition from one or
more of these storage classes over time
in order to save on your storage costs
that's really why we're doing this so
let's go through some of these storage
classes by default like I said whenever
you upload an object you automatically
get placed into the standard storage
class so any files that you're working
on frequently daily this is the best fit
for it got the highest level
of accessibility and durability as well
not that the others don't have the same
level of durability however we'll see
how when you transition from one
storage tier to the next some
characteristics do change in order for
you to save on some cost we're going to
go through some of those now this would
be considered hot data right data that's
used all the time maybe just by you
maybe by everybody right so that's the
perfect place to place it in the
standard storage class now over time
like I said you may find yourself
working
less and less perhaps on a document that
was due by the end of the month that
document was submitted and then
afterwards you don't work on that
document anymore perhaps you're only
working on revisions based on feedback
from your colleagues that are asking you
to make some corrections or some
amendments and so only those Corrections
or amendments come in perhaps once a
month and so in that case you might find
yourself
finding a justification for moving that
document from the standard tier to the
standard IA or infrequently accessed
here maybe any objects not modified for
more than 30 days are a good fit for
that and that's really the criteria for
IA in active access is that S3
or AWS itself recommends to only put
objects in there if they haven't been
asked to access for at least 30 days so
you get a a price reduction a rebate for
putting objects that are not accessed
frequently in here of course if you
remove objects let's say before the
30-day limit then you are charged a
surcharge for retrieving an object that
you said was infrequently accessed but
it really was not so bear that in mind
if you're going to place objects in in
frequent access
be somewhat reasonably assured that
you're not going to be going there and
accessing them you can still access
those files no problem just as quickly
they have the same level of
accessibility and durability however
like I said anything less than 30 days
you'll get a price ding on that
if you want to have long-term storage
we're talking about Amazon Glacier so
this is more anything over 90 days that
hasn't been modified or 180 days there's
two subcategories of Amazon Glacier that
we're going to get into and this is the
cheapest storage by far and Amazon
Glacier doesn't really operate through
the AWS console as the same as the
standard and the infrequent access you
can't really upload objects to Glacier
via the console in the browser
you can only do so let's say through the
command line interface or through an SDK
the only thing you can do on the web
console with Glacier is actually create
what's called a vault which is a logical
container for your archives but then
after that you have to go through the
CLI or the SDK to do the rest of the
work there
if we continue on there's some gray
areas between uh the S3 standard in a
glacier one is the one zone in
frequently accessed storage class so if
we go back to the regular standard and
IA storage class all of these objects
are stored across a minimum of three
availability zones
if you want a further price reduction
you can store your objects in a one zone
IA storage class which means that
instead of taking that object and
replicating it across three or more
availability zones it will only start in
a single availability Zone therefore
reducing
the level of availability that you have
to that object so in this case here if
that single availability Zone would go
down for example you would not have
access to that object once it would come
back up of course you would the other
thing is is if there was a an immense
catastrophe where the actual
availability Zone was destroyed will of
course then your object is also gone so
if that's something that doesn't worry
you because you have already many copies
of this object maybe lying around on
premise then this is a good option for
you because it's data that you're
willing to lose or lose access to for
short periods of time if ever that
single availability Zone goes down so
it's about an extra 20 off the price
from already the normal IA standard
price
there is another one called the standard
reduced redundancy storage
this one is kind of getting phased out
as we speak because the same price for
this storage class is about the same
amount you're going to pay for the
normal IA standard class what this does
is again is a good fit for
your objects that you're not really
worried about losing if there is some
sort of catastrophe that happens in an
availability Zone there's less copies of
it that are stored and so if that data
center and that availability Zone goes
down then you lose your object so of
course it offered at the time the
highest price reduction possible but now
the difference between this one and the
normal IA standard storage class is so
small in terms of price that you're
probably not going to migrate to or
navigate to this storage class but it is
still there in the documentation and it
may very well come up still in the
certification exam so at least be aware
of that
let's now take a look at some individual
features of S3 starting off with life
cycle management so life cycle
management is very interesting because
it allows us to come up with a
predefined rule that will help us
automate the transitioning of objects
from one storage class to another
without us having to manually copy
things over of course you could imagine
how time consuming that would be if we
had to do this manually
so we're going to see this very soon in
a lab however let me discuss how how
this works
so once we it's basically a graphical
user interface it's very very simple to
use once you come up with these
lifecycle management rules but you're
going to Define two things you're going
to define the transition action and the
expiration action so the transition
action is going to be something like
well I want to transition an object
from maybe it's all objects or maybe
it's just a specific type of object in a
folder example that has a specific
prefix from one storage class let's say
standard to standard inactive or
infrequent access maybe only after 45
days after at least a minimum of 30 days
like we spoke of before and then maybe
after
in 90 days you want to transition the
objects in IA to right away Glacier deep
archive or 180 days you come up with
whatever combination you see fit okay it
doesn't have to be sequential for ms3 to
IA to one zone etc etc because like we
discussed before it depends what kind of
objects that you're interested in
putting in one zone objects that you
don't really mind losing if that one
availability Zone goes down so you're
going to be deciding those rules
it ends up that this even is not a
simple task because you have to monitor
your usage patterns to see which data is
hot which data is cold and what's the
best kind of life cycle management to
implement to reap the benefits of the
lowest cost so you have to put somebody
on this job and make the best informed
decisions based on your access patterns
and that is something that you need to
consistently monitor
so what we can do is we can instead opt
for something called S3 intelligent
tiering
which basically analyzes your workload
using machine learning algorithms
and after about a good 30 days of
analyzing your access patterns will
automatically be able to transition your
objects from S3 standard to S3 standard
infrequent access okay it doesn't go
past the ia1 it doesn't go after the
glacier and whatnot okay so it can then
offer you
um that at a reduced price overhead so
there is a monitoring fee that is
introduced in order to implement this
feature it's a very nominal very very
low monitoring fee
and the nice thing is is if ever you
take out an object out of the infrequent
axis before the 30-day limit as we spoke
of before you will not be charged
um an overhead charge because of that
why because you're using the
intelligence tiering you're already
paying an overhead for the monitoring
fee so at least in that sense the
intelligent tearing will take the object
out of IA and put it back into the S3
standard class if you need access to it
before the 30 days and in that case you
will be charged that overhead so that is
something that is very
um that is very um good to to to do in
order not to have to put somebody on
that job so yes you're paying a little
bit of overhead for that monitoring fee
but at the other side of the spectrum
you're not investing in somebody uh
working many hours to Monitor and put
into place a system to monitor your data
access patterns so let's take a look at
how to do this right now let's Implement
our own
life cycle management rules
so let's now create a lifecycle rule
inside our bucket first off we're going
to need to go to the management tab
and the bucket that we just created and
right on the top you see right away life
cycle rule we're going to create
lifecycle Rule and we're going to name
it so I'm just going to say something
very simple like simply
learn
lifecycle rule
and we have the option of creating this
rule for every single object in the
bucket or we can limit the scope to a
certain type of file perhaps with a
prefix like
I could see one right now something like
logs so anything that we categorize as a
log file will transition from one
storage tier to the next as per our
instructions we're doing this because we
really want to save on costs right it's
not so much of organizing what's your
older data versus your newer data it's
more about
reducing that storage cost as your
objects get less and less used so in
this case the logs are a good fit
because perhaps you're using your logs
for the first 30 days you're sifting
through them you're trying to get
insights on them but then you kind of
move them out of the way because they
become old data and you don't need them
anymore so we're going to see how we can
transition them to another pricing tier
another storage tier
uh we could also do this with object
tags which is a very powerful feature
and in the lifecycle rules action you
have to at least pick one of these
options now since we haven't enabled
versioning yet what I'm going to do is
just select transition to current
version of the object between these
storage classes
so as a reminder of what we already
covered in the slides are storage
classes are right over here so the one
that's missing is obviously
the default standard storage class which
all objects are placed in by default so
what we're going to say is this we want
our objects that are in the default
standard storage class to go to the
standard inactive access storage class
after 30 days and that'll give us a nice
discount on those objects being stored
then we want to add another transition
and let's say we want to transition them
to Glacier after 90 days
and then as a big finale we want to go
to Glacier deep archive you can see the
rest are grayed out would it make sense
to go back and maybe after 180 days we
want to go there okay now there's a
little bit of um a warning or a call to
attention here they're saying if you're
going to store very small files into
Glacier not a great idea there's an
overhead in terms of metadata that's
added and also there's an additional
cost associated with storing small files
in Glacier so we're just going to
acknowledge that of course for the
demonstration that's fine in real life
you'd want to store a very big tar files
or zip files that had you know one or
more log files in there okay that would
bypass that that surcharge that you
would get
and over here you have the timeline
summary of everything we selected up
above so we have here after 30 days the
standard inactive access after 90 days
Glacier and after 180 days Glacier deep
archive so let's go and create that rule
all right so we see that the rule is
already enabled and at any time you
could go back and disable this if ever
you had a reason to do so we can easily
delete it as well or view the details
and edit it as well so if we go back to
our bucket
now what I've done
is created that prefix with the slash
logs since we're not doing this from the
command line we're going to create a
logs folder over here that will fit that
prefix so create logs
create folder
and now we're going to upload our let's
say our Apache log files in here so
we're going to upload one demonstration
Apache log file that I've created with
just one line in there of course just
for demonstration purposes we're going
to upload that
and now we have let me just close that
and now we have our our Apache log file
in there so what's going to happen
because we have that life cycle rule in
place after 30 days anything any file
that has the logs prefix where basically
is placed inside this folder will be
transitioned as per that life cycle row
policy that we just created so
congratulations you just created your
first S3 lifecycle rule policy
let's now move over to bucket policies
so bucket policies are going to allow or
deny access to not only the bucket
itself but the objects within those
buckets to either specific users or
other services that are inside the AWS
Network
now these policies fall under the
category of I am policy so IM stands for
identity and access management and this
is a whole other topic that deals with
security at large so there are no
services in AWS which are allowed to
access other services or data for
example within S3 without you explicitly
allowing it through these IM policies so
one of the ways we do that is by
attaching one of these policies which
are written in a Json format so it's a
text file that we write at the end of
the day that's the artifact and that's a
good thing because we can use that
artifact
and we can configuration control it in
our source control and version it and
put it alongside our source code
so when we deploy everything it is part
of our deployment package so in this
case here we have several ways of doing
this we can use What's called the policy
generator which is a graphical user
interface that allows us to Simply click
and point and populate certain text
boxes which will then generate that Json
document that will allow us to attach
that to our S3 bucket and that will
determine like I said which users or
Services have access to
whatever API actions are available for
that resource so we might say we want
certain users to be able just to list
the contents of this bucket not
necessarily be able to delete or upload
new objects into that bucket so you can
get very fine-grained permissions based
on the kind of actions you want to allow
on this resource so in order to really
we bring this home let's go and perform
our very own lab on this
let's now see how to create an S3 bucket
policy going back to our bucket we're
now going to go into permissions
so the whole point of coming up with a
bucket policy is that we want to control
who or what the what being other
services have access to our bucket and
our objects within our bucket so there
are several ways we can go about doing
this let's edit a bucket policy
one we can go and look at a whole bunch
of pre-canned examples which is a good
thing to do
two we could actually go in here and
code the Json document ourselves which
is much more difficult of course so what
we're going to do is we're going to look
at a policy generator which is really a
form-based graphical user interface that
allows us to generate through the
answers that we're going to give here
the Json document for us
first question is we got to select the
policy type of course we're dealing with
S3 so it makes sense for us to create an
S3 bucket policy
the two options available to us are
allowing or denying access to
RS3 bucket now in this case here we
could get really
um fine-grained and specify certain
kinds of services or certain kinds of
users but for the demonstration we're
just going to select star which means
anything or anybody can access this S3
bucket all right now depending on also
the actions that we're going to allow so
in this case here we can get very fine
grained and we have all these check
boxes that we can check off to give
access to certain kind of API action so
we can say we want to give access to you
know just deleting the bucket which
obviously is something very powerful but
you can get more fine-grained as you can
see you have more of the Getters over
here and you have more of the
the the listing and the putting new
objects in there as well so you can get
very fine grain now for demonstration
purposes we're going to say all action
so this is a very
Broad and wide ranging permission
something that you really should think
twice about before doing where it's
basically saying we want to allow
everybody and anything any service all
API actions on this S3 bucket so that's
no small thing
we need to specify the Amazon resource
name the Arn of that bucket specifically
so what we're going to do is go back to
our bucket
and you can see here uh the bucket Arn
okay so we're just going to copy this
paste it in this policy generator and
just say add statement you can see here
kind of a resume of what we just did and
we're going to say generate policy and
this is where it creates for us and make
this a little bit bigger for us it
creates that Json document so we're
going to take this we're going to copy
it and we're going to paste it into
the generator okay now of course we
could flip this and change this to a
deny
right which would basically say we don't
want anybody to have access or anything
any other service to have access to this
S3 bucket we could even say
slash star to also encapsulate all the
objects within that bucket so if I save
this right now
you have a very iron-clad
S3 bucket policy which basically denies
All Access
to this bucket and the objects within of
course this is on the other side of the
spectrum very very secure so we might
want to for example host a static
website
through our S3 bucket so in this case
here allowing access would make more
sense right so if I save changes you see
that we get an error here saying that we
don't have permissions to do this
and the reason for that is because it
realizes that this is extremely
permissive so in order to give access to
every single object within this bucket
as in the case that I was stating of a
static website being hosted on your S3
bucket it would be much better to also
it first enable that option so I'm just
going to duplicate the tab here
and once you go back to the permissions
tab one of the first things that shows
up is this block Public Access setting
right right now it's completely blocked
and that's what's stopping us from
saving our policy we would have to go in
here
unblock it and save it right and it's
also kind of like a double clutch
feature you have to confirm that just so
you don't do that by accident
right so now what you've effectively
done is you've really opened up the
floodgates to have public access to this
bucket it's something that can't be
accidentally done it's kind of like
having to perform these two actions
before the public access can be granted
now historically this was something that
AWS was
um
was guilty of was making it too easy to
have Public Access so now we have this
double clutch now that this is enabled
or turned off we can now save
our changes here successfully
and you can see here that now it's
publicly accessible which is a big red
flag that perhaps this is not something
that you're interested in doing now if
you're hosting a public website and you
want everybody just to have read access
to every single object in your bucket
yes this is fine however please make
sure that you
um
pay very close attention to this type of
access flagged over here on the console
so congratulations you just got
introduced to your first bucket policy a
permissive one but at least now you know
how to go through that graphical user
interface through the policy generator
and create them and paste them inside
your S3 bucket policy pane
so let's continue on with data
encryption so any data that you place in
S3 bucket can be encrypted at rest very
easily
using an AES 256 encryption key so we
can have server-side encryption we could
have AWS handle all the encryption for
us and the decryption will also be
handled by AWS when we request our
objects later on but we could also have
client-side encryption where we the
client that are uploading the object
have to be responsible for also passing
over our own generated key that will
eventually be used by AWS to then
encrypt that object on the bucket side
of course once that happens then the key
is discarded the client key is discarded
and you have to be very mindful that
since you've decided to handle your own
encryption client-side encryption that
if ever you lose those keys well that
data is not going to be recoverable in
that bucket on the AWS Network so be
very careful on that point
we can also have a very useful feature
called versioning which will allow you
to have a history of all the changes of
an object over time so versioning sounds
exactly how it's named every time you
make a modification to a file and upload
that new version to S3 it will have a
brand new version ID associated with
that so over time you get a sort of
stack of a history of all the file
changes over time so you can see here at
the bottom
you have an ID with all these ones and
then an ID with one two one two one two
So eventually if ever you wanted to
revert back to a previous version you
could do so by accessing one of those
previous versions of course versioning
is not an option that's enabled by
default you have to go ahead and enable
that yourself it is extremely simple
thing to do
and so there may be a situation where
you already have objects within your
buckets and you only then enable
versioning well versioning would only
apply to the new objects that would get
uploaded from the point that you enabled
versioning the objects that were there
before that point will not get a
specific version number attached in fact
they will have a sort of null marker the
version number that will get attached to
them it's only after that you modify
those objects later on and upload a new
version that they will get their own
version numbers
so right now what we're going to be
doing is a lab on actual versioning so
let's go ahead and do that right now
in this lab we're going to see how to
enable versioning in our buckets enabled
versioning is very easy we're simply
going to click on our bucket go into
properties and there is going to be a
bucket versioning section
I'm going to click on edit and enable it
once that's done any new objects
that are uploaded to that S3 bucket will
now benefit from being tracked by a
version number so if you upload objects
with the same file name after that
they'll each have a different version
number so you'll have version tracking a
history of the changes for that object
let's actually go there and upload a new
file
I'll upload one called index.html so
we're going to simulate a situation
where we've decided we're going to use
an S3 bucket as the source of our static
website to deploy one and in this
index.html file if you take a look right
now let's take a look at what's in there
you can see that we have welcome to my
website and we're at version two okay so
if I click on this file right now
and I go to versions
I can clearly see that there's some
version activity that's happening here
okay we have here
um at 1456 which is the latest one the
latest one is on the top the current
version we have a specific version ID
and then we have a sort of history of
what's going on here now I purposely
enabled versioning before and then try
to
delete version or disable versioning but
here's the thing with versioning you
cannot disable it fully once it's
enabled you can only suspend it
right now suspending means that whatever
version numbers those objects had before
you decided to suspend it will remain so
you can see I have an older version here
that has an older version number and at
this point here I decide to suspend
versioning and so what it does instead
of disabling the entire history it puts
what's called a delete marker okay you
could always roll back to that version
if you want now in the demonstration
when we started it together I enabled it
again so you can see this is actually
the brand new version number as we did
it together but you don't lose the
history of previous versioning if ever
you had suspended it before so that's
something to keep in mind right and
it'll come up in the exam where they'll
ask you can you actually disable
versioning once it's enabled and the
answer is no you can only suspend it and
your history is still maintained now we
have that version there and let's say I
come to this file and I want to upgrade
this I don't know I say version three
right and now it's going to happen
is if I click on this version this is
the current one with version two and I
open this we should see version two
which is fine that's that's that's
expected if we go back to our bucket and
upload that new version file that has
version three in there
they want to just modify it
we should now see in that index.html
file a brand new version that was
created
under the versions Tab and there you go
1458 just two minutes after you can see
here we have a brand new version ID
right and if I open this one
you can see version three so now you
have a way to enable versioning very
easily in your buckets and you also have
seen what happens when you want to
suspend versioning what happens to the
history of those versions files before
just to actually go back here to the
properties
uh where we enabled versioning in the
first place if I want to go back in here
and disable it like I said you can't
disable you can only suspend and that's
where that delete marker gets placed but
all your previous versions retain their
version ID so don't forget that because
that will definitely be a question on
your exam if you're interested in taking
the certification exam so
congratulations you just learned how to
enable
versioning
let's move on to cross region
replication or crr as it is known there
will be many times when you find
yourself with objects in a bucket and
you want to share those objects with
another bucket now that other bucket
could be within the same account could
be within another account within the
same region or could be within a
separate account
in a different region so there's varying
levels of degree there the good thing is
is all of those
um combinations are available so crr if
we're talking about cross region
replication is really about replicating
objects across regions something that is
not enabled by default because that will
incur a replication charge because it's
syncing objects across regions of course
you are spanning a very wide area
network in that case so there is a
surcharge for that
now doing so is quite simple to do but
one of the things that we have to be
mindful of is to give permissions for
the source bucket which has the
originals
to allow for this copying of objects to
the destination bucket so if we're doing
this across regions of course we would
have to come up with IM policies and we
would also have to exchange credentials
in terms of
I am user credentials in terms of
account IDs and and such we're going to
be doing a demonstration in the same
account in the same region but largely
this would be the same steps if we were
going to go cross region so this is
something you might find yourself doing
if you want to share data with other
um entities in your company maybe you're
a multinational and you want to have all
your lock files copied over to another
bucket in another region for another
team to analyze to extract business
insights from or it might just be that
you want to aggregate data in a separate
data Lake in an S3 bucket in another
region or in a like I said it could be
even in the same region or in the same
account so it's all about organizing
moving data around across objects across
these boundaries and let's actually go
through a demonstration and see how we
can do crr
let's now see how we can perform cross
region replication we're going to take
all the new objects that are going to be
uploaded in the simply learn S3 demo
bucket and we're going to replicate them
into a destination bucket so what we're
first going to do is create a new bucket
okay and we'll just tack on the number
two here and this will be our
destination bucket where all those
objects will be replicated to we're
going to demonstrate this within the
same account but it's the exact same
steps when doing this across regions
one of the requirements when performing
cross-region replication is to enable
versioning so if you don't do this you
can do it at a later time but it is
necessary to enable it at some point in
time before coming up with a cross
region replication rule
all right so let me create that bucket
and now after the bucket is created I
want to go to the source bucket and I
want to configure under the managements
tab here
a replication rule so I'm going to
create a replication rule call it
simply learn
rep rule
and I'm going to enable this right off
the bat
The Source bucket of course is the
simply learn S3 demo we could apply this
to all objects in the bucket or perform
a filter once again let's keep it simple
this time and apply to all objects in
the bucket of course caveat here this
will only now apply to any new objects
that are uploaded into this Source
bucket and not the ones that are already
pre-existing there okay now in terms of
the a destination bucket we want to
select the one we just created so we can
choose a bucket in this account or if we
really want to go cross region or
another account in another region we
could specify this and put in the
account ID in the bucket name in that
other account
so we're going to stay in the same
account we're going to browse and select
the newly created bucket
and we're also going to need permissions
for the source bucket to dump those
objects into the destination bucket so
we can either create the role ahead of
time or we can ask this user interface
to create a new role for us so we'll opt
for that
and we'll skip these additional
features over here that we're not going
to talk about in this demonstration
we're just going to save this so that
will create our replication rule that is
automatically enabled for us right now
so let's take a look at the overview
here you can see it's been enabled just
to double check the destination bucket
is the demo two we're talking about the
same region
and again here we could opt for
additional
um parameters like different storage
classes in the destination bucket that
that object is going to be deposited in
etc etc for now we just created a simple
rule now if we go back to
the original Source bucket which we're
in right now and we upload a new file
which will be transactions file in a CSV
format
once this is uploaded
that cross region replication rule
will kick in and will eventually right
it's not immediate but will eventually
copy
the file inside the demo 2 bucket now I
know it's not there already so what I'm
going to do is pause the video and come
back in two minutes and when I click on
this the file should be in there
okay so let's now double check and make
sure that object has been replicated
and there it is been replicated as per
our rule so congratulations you just
learned how to perform your first same
account S3 bucket region replication
rule
I'll take a look at transfer
acceleration
so transfer acceleration is all about
giving your end users the best possible
experience when they're accessing
information in your bucket so you want
to give them the lowest latency possible
you can imagine if you were serving a
website
uh and you wanted people to have the
lowest latency possible of course that's
something that's very desirable so in
terms of traversing long distances if
you have your bucket that is in for
example the U.S east wine region in the
United States in the Virginia region and
you had users let's say in London that
want to access those objects of course
they would have to Traverse a longer
distance than users that were based in
in the United States and so if you
wanted to bring those objects closer to
them in terms of latency then we could
take advantage of What's called the
Amazon Cloud front delivery Network the
CDN Network which extends the AWS
backbone by providing what's called
Edge locations so Edge locations are
really data centers that are placed in
major city centers where our end users
mostly are located more densely
populated areas and your objects will be
cached in those locations so if we go
back to the example of your end users
being in London well they would be
accessing a cached copy of those objects
that were stored in the original bucket
in the for example Us East one region of
course you will get most likely a
dramatic performance increase by
enabling transfer accelerations very
simple to enable this just bear in mind
that when you do so that you will incur
a charge for using this feature the best
thing to do is to show you how to go
ahead and do this so let's do that right
now
let's now take a look at how to enable
transfer acceleration on our simply
learn S3 demo bucket
by simply going to the properties tab we
can scroll down and look for a heading
called transfer acceleration
over here
and very simply just enable it
so what does this do
this allows us to take advantage of
What's called the content delivery
Network the CDN which extends the AWS
Network backbone
the CDN network is strategically placed
into more densely populated areas for
example major city centers and so if
your end users
are situated in these more densely
populated areas they will reap the
benefits of having transfer acceleration
enabled because the latency that they
will experience will be severely
decreased so their performance is going
to be enhanced if we take a look at the
speed comparison page for transfer
acceleration we can see that once the
page is finished loading it's going to
do a comparison it's going to perform
first of all what's called a multi-part
upload and it's going to see how fast
that upload was done with or without
transfer acceleration enabled now this
is relative to where I am running this
test so right now I'm actually running
it from Europe so you can see that I'm
getting very very good results if I
would enable transfer acceleration and
my users were based in Virginia so of
course now I have varying
uh differences in percentage as I go
closer or further away from my region
where my bucket or my browser is being
is being referenced so you can see here
United States I'm getting pretty good uh
percentages as I go closer to Europe it
gets lower of course but still very very
good Frankfurt again this is about us
probably the worst I'm going to be
getting here since I'm situated in
Europe
and of course as I go look more towards
you know the Asian regions you can see
once again it kind of scales up in terms
of better performance so of course this
is an optional feature once you enable
it as I just showed over here this is a
feature that you pay additionally for
so bear that in mind make sure that you
take a look at the pricing page in order
to figure out how much this is going to
cost you so that is it congratulations
you just learned how to
simply enable transfer acceleration to
lower the latency from the end user's
point of view
we're now ready to wrap things up in our
conclusion and go over at a very high
level what we just spoke about so we
talked about what S3 is which is a core
service one of the original Services
published by AWS in order for us to have
unlimited object storage in a secure
scalable and durable fashion we took a
look at other aspects of S3 in terms of
the benefits we mainly focused on the
cost savings that we can attain in S3 by
looking at different storage classes now
of course S3 is industry recognized as
one is the cheapest object storage
Services out there that has the most
features available we saw what goes into
the object storage in terms of creating
first our buckets which are our
containers high level containers in
order for us to store our objects in
again objects are really an abstraction
of the type of data that are in there as
well as the metadata associated with
those objects
we took a look at the different storage
tiers the default being this standard
all the way till the cheapest one which
is the glacier which are meant for a
long term archived objects for example
log files that you may hold on to for a
couple of years may not need to access
routinely and we'll have the cheapest
pricing option by far so we have many
pricing tiers and if you want to
transition from one tier to the next you
would Implement a life cycle policy or
use the intelligent tiering option that
can do much of this for you we took a
look at some very interesting features
starting from the life cycle management
policies that we just talked about all
the way to versioning cross region
replication and transfer acceleration so
with this conclusion you are now ready
to at least start working with S3 let me
help you understand about AWS ec2 a
compute servers in the cloud through
this video somewhere far in the country
a scientist has a lab far in the woods
and at one day he stumbled on a
calculation that he had trouble solving
and he was very certain that his
computer can handle it and he asked his
computer to do the math or the
calculation for him and the computer
thought about it for a while then took
couple of hours in trying to process the
data and eventually at one point it gave
up and died due to low memory and this
old scientist is now clueless about how
he was going to finish the task and
complete his invention and let the whole
world know about it and that's when he
was introduced to this new friend AWS as
you see on the screen AWS was very handy
in replacing his old machines and it was
able to give him the service that he
wanted at that moment AWS has been
around for a while helping people with
their computer needs and now this new
scientist friend in Nair is welcomed by
the new and trendy ID technology AWS and
sure enough his new AWS friend welcomed
and walked him through the new way of
computing and this new Happy faced AWS
friend talked to this scientist about
AWS ec2 in specific and walked him
through about all the new Innovations in
ID and in Cloud that he had been missing
all these days so his new friend AWS
started the conversation about
explaining how there is no need for any
hardware units no managing Hardware or
provisioning in AWS and secondly it
explained increasing and decreasing the
capacity as per the demand is just a
click away and the best part here is
that there is no upfront commitment and
we only pay for what we have used just
like we pay electricity and water bills
and all this comes with complete control
from our side other words the whole key
for this infrastructure is with us and
as if this was not enough all this comes
with Enterprise grade security that's
beyond imagination in on-premises and if
this tool does not excite you then this
definitely would you can work from
anywhere in the world now this really
made the scientist to get excited
especially when he thought about working
from home working from home there is
nothing like it isn't it now this person
the scientist is not tied up to a
particular environment he can work from
home work on the Fly work from anywhere
still the data and everything else in
his ID environment is secure and safe
now let's move to the next level of
discussion let's talk about what is ec2
and some of the use cases of ec2 and
this used case we're going to talk about
are this architecture we're going to
talk about it notifies a group of users
about a new letter and the components
are resources this architecture would
need be first ec2 instance then SNS a
simple notification service and coupling
ec2 and S3 service together that's all
it would require to get an architecture
that notifies a group of users about a
new newsletter and now I think it would
be a good time to talk about what ec2 is
AWS offers plenty of services offered
under different domains like you know
compute storage database migration
Network management tools Media Services
security business productivity
application integration machine learning
game development and lot more coming up
out of which ec2 falls under the compute
capacity so what is ec2 ec2 is a web
service which aims to make life easier
for Developers for providing secure and
resizable compute capacity in the cloud
with ec2 it is very easy to scale up or
scale down our infrastructure based on
the demand and not only that this ec2
service can be integrated well with
almost all the services in Amazon and
out of all this the best part could be
we only pay for what we use all right
let's talk about this use case a use
case here is that a successful business
owner has a bunch of users and a
successful product that's running and
now he has developed few more products
that he thinks will be very successful
that he thinks his customers are going
to like now how can he advertise his
product to his new and prospective
customers or the solution for this
question can be addressed by AWS in AWS
we can use services like simple
notification service SNS and ec2 for
compute and S3 for storage we can in a
way integrate them all and achieve leave
this business use case and that's where
I've got this business owner very chewed
up and now he wants to use the service
and he wants to get benefited from the
service he wants to advertise or he
wants to notify his users every time the
company creates a newsletter all right
so let's talk about what it would take
to get this environment up and running
or what it would take to connect the
environment and put the applications on
top of it firstly we would require an
AWS account and then for compute
capacity we would require an ec2
instance and here's how we go about
doing it the first thing is to create an
Ami which is Amazon Mission image that's
really the softwares and the application
packages we would need to run our
application and the second is to choose
the hardware in here it's the instance
type depending on the workload we would
be choosing the hardware and depending
on the intents of the workload we will
be choosing the size of the hardware and
find finally we would configure the
instances in a how many instance do I
want you know which subnet do I want
them in and what's going to be the in a
stop or terminate a behavior of the
instance and do I want to update any
patches when the instance starts running
all those speeds of information go in
here when we configure the instance and
then the first three steps is really
about the OS volume and the Basic
Hardware now it's time to add additional
storage to the ec2 instance that would
be step four here we add additional
storage to the ec2 instance and then
tags we use tags or we would configure
tags to easily identify an ec2 instance
at a later point you know we give it
some meaningful names so we can identify
like you know which team it belongs to
which billing department it belongs to
what's the purpose behind launching this
instance stuff like that in an
environment where we run 700 to 800 or
even more instances identifying an
instance and trying to to understand you
know who owns the resource for what
purpose we created it could be an
full-time work so tagging comes to a
rescue at that time after tagging as
step 6 we would configure the firewall
which is also called Security Group for
the ec2 instant and this is where we
would allow or deny connection from
external world to this particular ec2
instance well it works both ways from
outside and from inside out this
firewall blocks the connection based on
port number and IP address and finally a
step 7 we review all the configurations
that you have done and we make sure that
the configurations is what we wanted and
finally click on submit that's going to
launch an ec2 instance all right this
was just an overview of how to create an
ec2 instance now let's talk about each
and every step in detail so to begin
with let's talk about how to create an
Ami well the Ami is just a template a
template that's used to create a new
instance or an a new computer or a new
VM or a new machine based on the user
requirement the things that go into an
Ami are the software the operating
system the additional applications that
get installed in it stuff like that the
Ami will also contain software
information you know information about
operating system information about
access permission information about
volumes they all compact in the Ami
again the Ami is of two types one is
predefined Amis are called Amazon
provided Amis the other one would be
custom Mis the Amis that we create and
if you're looking at a particular Ami
that you don't want to create but still
want to get it from Amazon there is a
place or a portal called Ami Marketplace
there we get like thousands of Amis in
there available for us to shop and use
them on a pay as you go business model
and use them as pay as you go billing so
there you can search Ami that you're
looking for most probably you'll be able
to get it there now let's talk about
choosing the instance type the instance
type is basically the hardware
specification that's required for a
machine that we're trying to build and
the instant types is categorized into
five main families they are to begin
with it's compute optimized now compute
optimize gives us lots of compute power
a lot of processing power so if my
application is going to require a lot of
processing power I should be picking
compute optimized instance and the
second one is memory optimized now this
is very good for application that
require in-memory caching you know there
are some applications that performs well
with cash or through cash or the
application would create a lot of data
that it wants to keep in cash for
re-reading or for processing you know
for lengthy processing stuff like that
for those type of application education
this memory optimized instance that
comes within memory cache is a very good
use case and the third one is the
instant that comes with the GPU
otherwise called GPU optimized GPU
stands for graphical process unit and
this is very good for application that
deals with gaming this is very good for
application that's going to require
large graphical requirements and storage
optimized is the fourth option just like
the name says this is a very good use
case for storage servers and the fifth
family type is general purpose just like
the name says it's for general purpose
if you're not particular about the
family then you generally would end up
picking the general purpose because here
the services are sort of equally
balanced you know you'll find a balance
between the virtual CPU and the memory
and the storage and the network
performance it's sort of balanced all
the components all the features that
needs to go on a computer are sort of
balanced in general purpose now these
instant types are fixed and they cannot
be altered because it's Hardware based
we buy Hardware we do not have much
control on the hardware that's being
used well we have options but we do not
have control on the hardware and these
instant types are divided into five main
families they are computer optimized
memory optimized GPU enabled storage
optimized and general purpose then as
third thing we have to configure the
instance now here is where I have a lot
of options about purchasing you know
what type of purchasing do I want to do
do I want to go for a spot instance do I
want to go for a reserved instance do I
want to go for an on-demand instance
these are different billing options
available and that's available under
configure instance not only that here's
where I'm going to put the ec2 instance
do I want an public IP address assigned
to it do I want an IAM role attached to
it IM role is authentication what kind
of authentication am I going to provide
and the the shutdown Behavior the Sharon
behaviors include do I want to stop the
instance when the user shuts down the
machine from the desktop or do I want to
Simply terminate this instance when the
user shuts down the instance from the
desktop so those things go in here just
like the name says configure instance
lot of instance configuration options
comes in here that's the third step and
not only that under the advanced details
or Advanced tab under configure instance
I can bootstrap the instance with some
scripts now bootstrap is nothing but the
scripts that you want to be run in the
instance before it actually comes online
let's say you're provisioning the
instance for somebody else you know
instead of you launching the instance
and then logging in and running some
commands and then handing it over to the
other person you can create bootstrap
shell scripts and you know paste it in a
console option available under configure
instance and Amazon is going to take
those commands run it on the insta
instance before it hands over to the
user that initially requested for that
instance now it could be a different
user or just you it sort of automates
you know software installation
procedures in the instance that we will
be launching and not only that there are
multiple payment options available under
configure instance the user can pick an
instance under normal price and that
instance would apply normal rates
applied to it and there are also options
like reserved instance where the user
can pay for an instance upfront before a
year or before months you know for a
span of year or a span of months and
that way they can pay less per hour for
using that instance not only that you
can also go for spot instance like
bidding for those instances whoever bids
more they get the instance for that
particular time well these instances are
a lot cheaper than on-demand instances
and through bidding and buying you can
keep the instance as long as your bid
price doesn't exceed the price that
Amazon is proposing and as the fourth
step we will have to add storage to the
instance that we are about to launch and
here we have bunch of storage options I
can go for a permanent storage which is
free or I can go for an external elastic
block storage also called EBS which is
paid and it's a permanent storage or
else I can integrate my ec2 instance
with S3 for its storage needs and the
best part about storage is a free
subscription users they get to use 30
gigabit of SSD storage or magnetic
storage for the whole year in this page
where we are ready to add storage we
will have to mention or provide the size
in gigabit and the volume type is it
going to be an provisioned volume is it
going to be an general purpose volume is
it going to be a magnetic volume stuff
like that there are volume types and we
also need to give inputs about where the
disk will be mounted and whether this
volume needs to be encrypted or not so
all these options are all these inputs
are received from us under the adding
storage section and then the fifth
option would be adding tags like we
discussed sometime back tags are very
helpful to identify a machine in an
environment where we have 700 or 1000
VMS running and security groups are the
actual firewall that sits in front of
ec2 instance and it protects that ec2
instance from unintended inbound and
outbound traffic now here is where I can
fine tune the access to my ec2 instance
based on port numbers and based on IP
address from which it can be accessed
and finally we get to review the whole
changes or the whole configurations that
we have made to find out whether they
are intact with the requirement and then
click on submit that's going to launch
an ec2 instance but hold on we're not
done yet when we're about about to
launch or before the Amazon console
actually launches the ec2 instance it's
going to give us an option to create a
keypad remember I said it's key pair you
know key pair is two things one is
public and private the private key is
downloaded by the user and is kept with
the user and the public key is used by
Amazon to confirm in the identity of the
user so just go ahead and download the
private key and keep it for yourself and
this private key gets downloaded as a
DOT pem file it's a format of the file
and it gets downloaded as dot pem file
and our next step is to access the ec2
instance and because the instance that
we have launched in this example let's
assume it's Linux instance and that's
going to require a tool called putty to
be able to access it and this putty tool
is really needed when we're trying to
access a Linux instance from Windows
instance most of the time Windows
instance will have put the install in
them but in some rare cases they do not
come with putty in those cases we can go
ahead and download putty and putty
generator and we can start using it to
access the Linux instance now you might
ask well I understand put you what's
putty generator now the file that we
have downloaded is in dot Pam format but
unfortunately putty does not accept dot
pem format as input you know it has to
be converted into a different format
called PPK and put it gen is a tool that
helps us to convert the dot pem file
into PPK file so as a quick way to do it
is download generator open it up click
on conversion and insert the dot pem key
that we have downloaded and save the
private key and this when we save the
private key it gets saved as a DOT PPK
type private key and when that's done
the next very step is to open putty and
try to log in and the way to log in is
to open putty put that IP address here
and then click on auth you know this is
where we would input the file that we
have created so click on off and then
click on browse and find the dot pbk
file that we have converted and stored
browse it and upload it and then click
on open now that's going to open up a
login screen for us and the Amis comes
with a default username depending on the
Ami that we have picked the username
might differ in our case we have picked
an Ami for which the username is ec2
hyphen user and this is the default by
the way let's put the username ec2
hyphen user and hit enter and that's
going to open up the Linux instance
using CLI there are a few other things
that we can do with the terminal that
will explain it a little later alright
so we have successfully launched an ec2
instance and yeah give yourself a pat on
your back launching an instance was just
one part of the solution so let's
actually talk about how we can notify
our customers SNS or simple notification
service is a service or a product in
Amazon that helps us to notify customers
through email so navigate to SNS in your
account and create a topic and we're
going to use this topic for public
notification so let's make it public and
then add subscribers to it now these
subscribers these subscribers are the
people who you want to be notified about
the newsletter so we already have the
email database in there add them to the
subscribers list and then they will
start getting new newsletters as and
when we post them to the topic and as
Next Step create a bucket in S3 where
you can store content and in that bucket
create an event that triggers a
notification to simple notification
service so this is how it will be set up
and notification will be sent to our
subscribers anytime we put something in
our S3 bucket so S3 bucket is going to
create an event for the notification and
the notification is going to make sure
that it's delivered to your end Customer
because they're already subscribed to
the topic as subscribers and finally
let's connect the S3 with ec2 so the
bucket and the AWS instance are in sync
so we put some content in the S3 bucket
our email system notifies our customers
and the customers can go online to a
website that's hosted in ec2 and because
S3 and ec2 are in sync the items that we
put in S3 will also show up in ec2 see
how this is all connected and it's
working together and once this is all
connected our subscribers will regularly
be informed anytime we put new content
in the S3 bucket and the same content
will be made available in ec2 instance
through the website so what did we learn
we learned about how ec2 can replace the
hardware system for computing and we can
go virtual where we don't have to manage
anything and also the environment is
scalable in a couple of button clicks
and it also provides pay as we go type
of subscription and not only that we
have full control of the environment and
it's highly secure at the same time and
then we learned about what ec2 is what
ec2 can do and how well it integrates
with other services in Amazon we also
looked at in detail about how to
provision an ec2 instance a step-by-step
approach and finally we talked about a
use case finally we talked about a use
case where a business owner wants to
notify his users about the new product
that he is developing and anytime that's
available he wanted an email to go out
to the customer notifying about the new
product and the customers can come
online and check it on the ec2 instance
that he was running AWS Lambda tutorial
one day at office in a growing company
there was this question going on between
two IT personnel it was about the new
role that his colleague Jessica has
taken Benjamin the guy standing here
wants to know about it and Jessica's job
is new different and dynamic and
interesting too she scale and manage
servers and operating systems and apply
security patches onto them and monitor
all of these at the same time to ensure
the best quality for application is
given to the users and Benjamin was
awestruck with the amount of work
Jessica is doing and with the time it
would take to complete all of them but
Jessica being a very Dynamic person very
suitable for the job said it was easy
for her to handle all of it and even
more but that easiness on the job did
not last longer as the Environ grew more
and more it being a startup company
Jessica was getting drained and was not
really happy about all her job as she
used to be Jessica's manual way of
scaling and environment did not last
long and she was also finding out that
she missed to scale down some of the
resources and it's costing her a lot she
needs to pay for the service that she
was not at all using she sort of felt
that she was at the end of the role and
there was no way out from this manual
task she was very desperate and that's
when Benjamin suggested something and
that brought back the peace and joy
Jessica initially had Benjamin suggested
about a service called Lambda that can
ease the work that Jessica is doing at
the moment and Lambda as happy as it
looks like it's a solution that solves
the manual repetitive work and lot more
and Lambda introduced itself as the
problem solver and started to explain
the following things the very same thing
that we're gonna learn about in this
series so in this section we're going to
learn about the features of AWS Lambda
and we're going to talk about what
Lambda is and then we're going to talk
about where Lambda is being used in the
it or in the cloud environment as we
speak and then we're going to talk about
how Lambda works and some use cases of
Lambda and we're going to be
particularly discussing about the use
case about automatically backing up the
data that's put in the cloud storage
let's talk about Lambda in detail Lambda
automatically runs our code without
requiring us to provision or manage
servers just write the code and upload
it to Lambda and Lambda will take care
of it that means that we don't require
any server to run or to manage and all
you need to do is write the code and
upload it to Lambda and Lambda will take
care of it which also means that we can
stop worrying about provisioning and
managing service the only thing Lambda
expects from you is a code that's
working AWS Lambda also automatically
scales our application by running code
in response to each trigger our code
runs in parallel and processes each
triggers individually scaling precisely
with the size of the workload scaling
here is done automatically based on the
size of the workload Lambda can scale
the application running the code in
response to each and every trigger that
it receives billing in Lambda is meter
on the seconds we only pay for the
amount of time that our code is running
which means that we're not charged for
any of the servers the only payment
required is for the amount of time the
code is computed with AWS Lambda we are
charged for every 100 milliseconds we
are actually charged for 100
milliseconds our code executes and the
number of times our code is triggered
and we don't pay anything when the code
is not running let's talk about what is
AWS Lambda now Lambda is one of the
service that falls under the compute
section or the compute domain of
services that AWS provides along with
ec2 EBS elastic load balancer Lambda is
also a service that comes under the
bigger umbrella of compute services in
in AWS and Lambda allows us to execute
code or any type of application with AWS
Lambda we can run code for virtually any
type of application or backend Services
all we need to do is supply our code in
one of the languages that AWS Lambda
supports as we speak the languages that
are supported by AWS Lambda are node.js
Java c-sharp go and Python and Lambda
can be used to run code in response to
certain events from other services and
based on the event it can run functions
and those functions can be of node.js
java c-sharp Etc now let's talk about
where is Lambda used there are huge
number of use cases for Lambda and there
are many ways AWS Lambda is used
specifically in the business world let's
talk about some of them one use case is
AWS Lambda is used to process images
when it is uploaded in an S3 bucket
let's say the object gets uploaded in an
S3 bucket in a form met that we don't
expect it to be which means the file
needs to be formatted so it gets
uploaded in a raw format and AWS Lambda
is triggered anytime a new object is
added to the bucket and the images are
processed and converted into thumbnails
based on the devices the other end
device that could be reading the data it
could be and PC it could be an apple
machine it could be an Android phone it
could be an Apple phone it could be a
tablet What Not So based on the devices
different formats Lambda can get
triggered and convert video or convert
the picture into the different format
that it requires another use case for
Lambda is to analyze the social media
data let's say let's say we're
collecting the hashtag trending data and
the data is received and it's added into
the Kinesis stream to feed into the
Amazon environment and Lambda action get
triggered and it receives the data and
there and the data is stored into the
database which can be used by businesses
for later analysis and some of the
companies that have gotten tremendous
benefit using Lambda or Thompson routers
benchlings Nordstrom Coca-Cola robot are
some of the companies to name at the
moment that have received tremendous
amount of benefit by using Lambda let's
look at how Lambda Works in other words
let's look at how the complicated
function behind the scenes work in a
simple and in a seamless way so here
clients send data now clients send data
to Lambda and clients could be anyone
who's sending requests to AWS Lambda it
could be an application or other Amazon
web services that's sending data to the
Lambda and Lambda receives the request
and depending on the size of the data or
depending on the amount or volume of the
data it runs on the defined number of
containers if it is a single request or
if it is less request it runs on a
single container so the requests are
given to the container to handle and the
container which contains the code the
user has provided to satisfy the query
would run and if you're sort of new to
Containers then let me pause here for a
while and explain to you what container
is now container image is a lightweight
Standalone executable package of a piece
of software that includes everything
needs to run it like the codes the
runtimes the system tools the system
libraries and any of the settings needed
and it is at the moment available both
on Linux and windows based application
and containerized software will always
run the same regardless of the
environment it's running on and
containers isolate software from its
surrounding for example there could be
difference between a development and
staging environment so that's sort of
isolated and this helps in reducing the
conflict between the teams running
different software on the same
infrastructure all right now that we
know containers needed to understand
Lambda so if there are few requests it
sends to a single container but as and
when the request grows it actually
creates multiple containers shares the
multiple requests to the different
containers there and depending on the
volume depending on the size depending
on the number of sessions the more
number of containers are provisioned so
to handle those requests and when the
request reduce the number of containers
reduce as well and that helps in Saving
costs we're not running any resources
and paying for it when we're not using
them and in fact we're not at all paying
for the resources we'll only charge for
the amount of time a function is running
inside these containers now consider a
situation where you have to set up a
temporary storage and as a system to
backup the data as soon as the data is
uploaded which is a near real-time
backup now a near real-time manual
backups are nearly impossible and
they're not that efficient too A near
real-time manual backups that's what the
business demands but that's not near
real-time backup that too a manual one
that's not at all efficient even if we
come up with a solution of manually
backing up close to near real Time
That's not going to be efficient looking
at the amount of data that will be put
in and looking at the random times the
data will be put into the source bucket
and there is no way we can do a manual
backup and they keep it as real as
possible but if that's still your
requirement we can use AWS Lambda and
set things up so AWS Lambda manually
handles the backup in other words for an
impossible or a difficult situation like
that AWS Lambda comes for the rescue and
this is what we do create a 2s3 bucket
one would be the source bucket where
where the data will be uploaded and the
other one is and destination bucket
where the data will be backed up from
the source bucket and for these buckets
to talk to themselves it's going to
require an IM role and then for the
automatic copy it's going to require an
Lambda function to copy the files from
The Source bucket to the destination
bucket and what triggers the Lambda
function the Lambda function is
triggered every time there's a change in
the metadata for the bucket and this
data is then uploaded into the
destination bucket and after setting all
this up we can literally test it by
putting a data in the source bucket
that's going to automatically replicate
or that's going to automatically copy
the data from The Source bucket to the
destination bucket all right let's see
how we can replicate data between two
bucket well we have a feature to cross
region replicate in S3 that's a feature
that comes along with S3 what if you
want to replicate between two different
buckets in two different accounts in
those cases we can use Lambda to
replicate the data between the buckets
so you put one data or you put data in
the source bucket and that data gets
replicated to the destination bucket and
let's see how that's done the procedure
here would be to have two buckets to
begin with and then create an IM role
that lets you access to pull data from
The Source bucket and put data on the
destination bucket and then create
Lambda files or Lambda event or triggers
to actually look for event in the source
bucket and anytime a new data gets added
Lambda gets triggered copies the data
from The Source bucket and moves the
data to the destination bucket and it
uses the IAM role and policy for the
needed permissions and in just a couple
of clicks we have set up a temporary
backup system that can run seamlessly
without any manual intervention and that
can be as near real time as possible
alright that's the concept and let's see
how it is done real time through the
slab so to begin with we need two
buckets so I have here a source bucket
and a destination bucket and the source
bucket as of now do not have any data in
it so as the destination bucket all
right so that's one down the second
would be to create an IM role right so
let me create an IM role and the role is
going to have this policy in it a policy
that's allowing get object on the source
bucket and a policy that's allowing put
object on the destination bucket and
here I'm going to use or I'm going to
paste my source and destination buckets
Arn all right go to Services go to S3
Source bucket
all right click on the source bucket and
copy the bucket Arn
so that would be the source bucket Arn
right on on the destination bucket copy
the destination bucket Arn
and this is going to be my destination
bucket Arn so with this I'm going to
create a policy
all right
go to iam
and create a policy
now I I have already created a policy
with the same information all right
destination bucket Arn and a policy is
available with the name S3 bucket copy
Lambda attach the policy to the role
right go to rules create a role Lambda
is the service that's going to use it in
here attach the policy that we have
created
right give it the name
and then create a role now I have a role
created as well
all right copy Lambda and that's having
the policy that we have created some
time back now create a Lambda function
right so go to Lambda
create a function give it a name like S3
bucket copy all right choose a role that
we want to use
all right that's the rule that we want
to use copy one two
create a function
all right
and then here we're going to use node.js
code right I have a sample code
this can be used as template in here
replace the source bucket with the name
of the source bucket and the destination
bucket with the name of the destination
bucket this is a node.js code that gets
run when an event get triggers now
what's an event anytime there is a new
object placed in the S3 bucket it
creates an event and the evil triggers
Lambda and Lambda checks this Source S3
bucket picks the data puts it in the
destination bucket all right paste it
here
paste it here and click on save all
right now before we click on Save just
ensure that you have the appropriate
rules defined that's all you got to do
click on save all right now I I already
have created
a Lambda function
all right
which is the same thing same code and
the rule is attached to it
now it's running it's active now let's
put this to test go to S3
pick the source bucket
put some data in it
all right and in theory those data
should be present in the destination
bucket as well
there you go it's all done by Lambda all
right so what did we learn so far we
started a discussion with the benefits
of Lambda like we don't have to worry
about the server when we use Lambda we
don't have to worry about scaling for
Lambda it automatically scales up and
scales down we don't have to worry about
the cost as well because we're only
paying for the seconds the code is
running and and when the code is not
running we're not paying anything to it
and then we spoke about what is AWS
Lambda what it contains of and what it
can do and then we discuss about the use
cases of Lambda and then we had a brief
discussion about how Lambda really works
and how it scales up and scales Down
based on the number of requests that it
receives and finally we did a quick lab
about how Lambda can be used for
automatic backups let's look into what
we have today in the cloud front
so what's in it for you we would be
covering up the concept of what is AWS
what was earlier uh before AWS
cloudfront after AWS cloudfront what
were the services that were introduced
how it benefited what do we mean by AWS
cloudfront benefits of the using AWS
cloudfront and how AWS cloudfront
actually is known as a Content delivery
service the name of the companies that
are using AWS cloudfront and we would be
covering up on live demo
now AWS is the Amazon web services it's
a cloud service provider that basically
offers a multiple Services variety of
services such as compute power database
storage networking and other resources
so that you can create your Solutions on
the cloud and help the business grow now
with AWS you only pay for whatever the
services you use so for example if you
are using a service for a couple of
hours then you pay for only that many
hours that you have use that service
before AWS cloudfront so there is an
example that we are going to talk and
that is you must be aware of an
application called Spotify so when you
used to access Spotify and when you
click on it it kept on loading and at
the end you used to get the error and
the error was that the connection failed
and why you received that error because
of a latency issue probably a network
error right so how you can solve these
kind of a latency issues and that is
also going to these kind of an issues
are also going to impact the performance
of an application
so with the introduction of AWS cloud
from this problem of loading the
application got result so after AWS
cloudfront with the help of adults
cloudfront Spotify gives the facility of
updating new features taxes to million
songs that you can access instantly
so with the use of AWS cloudfront or the
latency issues were solved and
successfully you can basically access
your application now
what we mean by AWS cloudfront so AWS
cloudfront is a globally distributed
Network that is offered by AWS Amazon
web services which securely delivers
content to the end users across any
geography with a higher transfer speed
and an improve or a low latency now what
are the benefits of AWS cloudfront there
are multiple benefits one is the cost
effective so it helps you to do the cost
optimization when you use the cloud
front it is time saving so it is
implemented easily and also lot of
issues with respect to accessing the
application with respect to latency and
all can be resolved
content privacy so the content is placed
to the end users and also to the
cloudfront servers in a secured manner
in a secured way it is highly
programmable and you can make the
changes amend the changes on the Fly
and you can Target any location any
geography across the globe along with
that it helps you to get the content
delivered quickly now how AWS cloudfront
delivers the content let's look into the
architecture
so this is a flow and the flow is with
respect to how the user is going to get
a content from the cloud front now the
client first access our website by
typing a URL on the browser and in the
step one it acts tries to access the
application then the client requests
when the website is open the client
request for an object to download such
as for example a particular file now at
that time the DNS routes user request to
download that file to AWS cloudfront
the AWS Cloud front connects to the
nearest Edge locations Edge locations
are basically the servers where it
caches
the files documents and the web codes
AWS cloudfront connects to its nearest
Edge location in order to serve the user
the request
at Edge location
AWS cloudfront looks for its requested
cache file once the file is found let's
say if the file is available in the case
of an edge location AWS cloudfront then
sends the file to the user otherwise if
the file is not found in the cache
memory of an edge location
AWS cloudfront compares the requirement
with the specification and share it with
a respected server that means a web
server or a server where the file is
actually available the server the web
server responds to the edge location by
sending the file back to the cloud front
edge location
and then as soon as the AWS cloudfront
receives the file it shares with the
client also adds the file to the cache
of an edge location for a future
reference this is how the flow of a
cloud front is now
the name of the companies that are using
the AWS cloudfront
so one of them is jio 7 app it is which
is a very popular app so it uses Amazon
cloudfront to deliver 15 petabytes of
audio and video to its subscribers
globally which is a huge data Sky News
uh it uses the service in order to unify
the content for faster distribution to
script subscribers
or the discovery Communications uh also
uses the cloudfront it uses the service
for delivering API static asset and also
the dynamic content
and then the tb1 EU streaming Europe is
basically also uses the cloudfront
service that helps in improving latency
and performance
that results in fastest delivery of
content
now let's look into the demo how to use
cloudfront to serve private S3 bucket as
a website
now I'm going to
run a cloudfront distribution demo on
the AWS console and uh we basically try
to deliver the content from a private S3
bucket and then map that with the domain
name using the root 53 service
so what we need for this demo we would
need a domain URL we would need a Route
53 service
we would need
cloudfront we have to create a
cloudfront distribution and that will be
linked with our S3 bucket the private S3
bucket right and in the S3 bucket we
would have one HTML file the index.html
file
so let's uh move into AWS console
so right now I have opened up the
cloudfront distribution
and here you can see uh that couple of
distributions have already been created
so what I'm going to do I'm going to
create a distribution
now there are two types of delivery
method for your content one is the web
distribution and the other one is rtmp
rtmp stands for Real Time audio or video
distribution it's basically used for
distribution of a media content or a
media file which are available in the S3
bucket
here we are going to select a web
distribution because primarily we will
be using files which uses protocols HTTP
or the https
so you have to click on get started
and in the origin domain name you have
to specify the bucket where your code is
available
so I have a bucket already created here
you can see and what you need to do is
you have to create a bucket with the URL
name or the domain name which you would
be mapping with the Route 53 service
so this is a bucket that has already
been created let me show you in a new
tab
so here you have to go to the storage
under the storage you have to select the
S3 bucket
let's open the link in the new tab and
let's look into
how we can create the S3 buckets
now here are a couple of buckets already
created I have created one bucket with a
domain name that I'm going to use and
map it with the root 53 service
so that is basically mapped to a region
which is in Ohio
and if you open up this bucket
here you will find an HTML web page the
index.html has been already added
right so similarly you have to create a
bucket with a domain and an index.html
page needs to be uploaded there
now again we'll go to the cloud front we
will try to create a distribution
just have to click on create
distribution
select a web delivery method
select An Origin domain which is
sunshinelearning.in
and origin path you don't have to
specify origin ID is this one so
basically when you define An Origin
domain name automatically the origin ID
appears
you can customize this origin ID as per
your requirement also
so rest of the things primarily we keep
it as a default settings only until and
unless if we require some customized
settings to be done
so let's say if you have to change the
cache Behavior settings you can do that
otherwise we'll keep it as default
now in the distribution setting you can
either select use all Edge locations for
the best performance so what does AWS uh
basically do here it uses all the edge
locations which are associated with AWS
across the globe otherwise you can
specify based on the regions also right
apart from that if you want to enable
firewalls or the access controllers you
can specify here
and then
what you need to do is in the default
root object here you have to specify
your index.html
pitch which is in the S3 bucket
the distribution state has to be enabled
and if you want to use ipvision 6 as
well you need to enable it
click on create distribution
now you you can see here a distribution
has been created it's in progress and it
is enabled
and it takes around 15 to 20 minutes to
get that distribution completed the
reason is that the web codes the web
pages will be
distributed across all the edge
locations across the globe so hence it
takes time to get that done right anyway
let's move on to Route 53 service
and let's create the hosted zones
so we'll type Route 53 here scalable DNS
and domain name registration
and what we are going to do here is
we are going to map our URL the domains
pointed to
the name servers that will be provided
by the root 53 so we have to create a
hosted Zone
let's wait for it
so now the root 53 dashboard is open and
you can see one hosted zone is already
created so just click on the hosted
zones
and in order to point the traffic from
the external domains towards the AWS you
have to first point the domain's traffic
to the
uh hosted Zone in the route 53.
so
I'll click on create hosted Zone but
before that I will first delete the
existing one
and then I'll create another record
Another hosted Zone
right
put your domain name let's put a
sunshinelearning.in
and it is acting as a public hosted Zone
rest of the things will be default click
on create hosted Zone
now it gives you phone name servers and
these phone name servers has to be
updated in the domain so you have to
update these name servers in a platform
from where you have purchased the domain
right so this is half of the work done
then what you need to do is you have to
go and create records
now in the records you can select a
routing policy so right now what we are
targeting we are targeting basically
that the traffic from the domain should
be pointed directly towards the cloud
front distribution hence we are going
with a simple routing right now
click on next
here you have to specify the record set
so we are going to create the records
uh just click on default simple record
put here as worldwide web
and you have to select an endpoint so
endpoint we are selecting for the cloud
front distribution so we have to specify
Alias for the cloud front distribution
now here we are going to put the
cloudfront distribution URL and then we
are going to define the simple report
set
so what we need is we need a cloudfront
distribution URL which you can find it
uh from the cloudfront service itself
and you can find the domain name here
itself
you just have to copy that
and then
paste it here in the distribution
and then just click on Define simple
records again click on create records
and here you can see
the record set has been updated now this
domain is basically pointed towards
these name servers which are further
pointed towards the cloudfront
distribution
right now the only thing which is left
is that
within the domain from wherever you have
purchased the domain you should update
these phonem servers and then you can
see the live traffic coming on this
domain will have an output from the
cloudfront distribution
a virtual private cloud or VPC refers to
a virtual Network for your AWS account
in the AWS Cloud a VPC is logically
secluded from other virtual networks to
ensure powerful networking and security
for your compute resources
a subnet in Amazon VPC refers to a
segment of the range of IP addresses and
is a subdivision in an availability Zone
preferred instances are launched into
this subnet
a subnet allows you to group instances
according to your operational and
security requirements
Amazon VPC allows launching AWS
resources into the virtual Network which
is a logically isolated area containing
Cloud resources
for Amazon ec2 Amazon VPC acts as the
networking layer as you pay only for its
used resources
there is no additional cost for the
using of Amazon VPC service
it is similar to a traditional Network
running in your data center but allows
to use the scalable AWS infrastructure
and enjoy complete control over your
virtual Network
with Amazon VPC you can select from a
range of IP addresses create subnets and
configure Network gateways and routing
tables
it also gives you the power to customize
the network configuration
for example you can place the back end
systems such as database servers in a
private subnet and web servers in the
public subnet for connecting to the
internet
you can also connect the Amazon VPC to
your data center by establishing a
virtual private Network or VPN
connection this helps in rendering the
AWS Cloud as an extension of your data
center
with Amazon VPC you can also leverage
several security layers by including
access control lists or ACLS and
different security groups
this enables you to control access of
instances in each subnet
the significant benefits of Amazon vpcr
first it offers several connectivity
options
for example you can connect the Amazon
VPC to other vpcs your data center
internet and based on the AWS resources
you choose to make public or private
second it is easy to create an Amazon
VPC in minutes using the AWS Management
console
while creating a VPC AWS automatically
assigns the security groups IP ranges
subnets and routing tables
as a result you can focus on creating
the applications that will run in the
VPC
third Amazon VPC offers Advanced
security features such as ACLS and
security groups to filter inbound and
outbound traffic
these features are available at the
subnet and instance levels
you can even restrict access to the
store data so that it is accessible only
from the instances in the VPC
AWS even lets you run instances on
Hardware of a single user for additional
isolation
lastly you enjoy the scalability and
reliability benefits of AWS
Amazon VPC offers all benefits that the
remaining AWS platform provides
you can immediately scale the Resources
pay only for the resources used and
specify types of instances suitable for
your applications
by launching the instances into a VPC
you can run instances on the hardware
used by a single entity
split the range of private IP addresses
of VPC into one or more private or
public subnets to run services and
applications in that VPC
allocate multiple IP addresses to the
instances
allocate static private IP addresses to
the instances that continue to run
across starts and stops
Define network interfaces and Associate
one or more interfaces into your
instances
control the inbound traffic to instances
which is known as Ingress filtering and
control the outbound traffic from
instances which is known as egress
filtering
add an extra layer of Access Control to
instances which is in the form of ACLs
change the membership of security group
of instances when they are running
in each availability Zone the default
VPC contains a subnet it is ready to use
and offers the advanced features of the
ec2vpc platform
when you do not mention a subnet despite
having a default VPC the Amazon ec2
instance launches into your default VPC
despite having an AWS account that
supports only the ec2 VPC platform you
can create and configure a VPC as per
your requirements
the additional subnets in the default
VPC and subnets in a non-default VPC are
termed as non-default subnets
when you open the VPC wizard it shows
four scenarios
there are four basic Network topologies
and you need to select the one that
resembles the topology you wish to
create
VPC with a single public subnet scenario
or topology
VPC with public and private subnets
VPC with public and private subnets and
Hardware VPN access
VPC with a private subnet only and
Hardware VPN access
VPC with a single public subnet allows
running a single-tier web application to
be made publicly available such as a
simple website or a Blog
you can ensure the security and privacy
of such applications by defining the
security group rules that enable the web
server to respond to the incoming and
outgoing requests
VPC with public and private subnets
allow running a public web application
and ensuring the private back-end
servers continue to run in another
subnet
you can use this scenario to host
multi-tier web applications and
enforcing access restrictions between
databases application servers and web
servers through security groups and ACLs
you can launch the application servers
and databases in private subnets and web
servers in public subnets the
application servers and databases can
access the internet to download and
install patches when you set up a
network address translation or Nat
Gateway the NAT Gateway allows instances
in a private subnet to connect to other
AWS services including the internet but
prohibits the AWS services to connect
with instances in the private subnet
this ensures higher bandwidth with less
administrative effort
VPC with public and private subnets and
Hardware with VPN access allows
accessing the World Wide Web directly
from your VPC
it also facilitates expanding your data
center into the AWS cloud
you can consider this option for hosting
scalable web applications connected to
your data center
this topology allows creating a VPC
where instances such as web servers in a
subnet connect to the World Wide Web
at the same time instances such as
application servers in the other subnet
communicate with databases of your
business Network
application servers and web servers can
take the benefits of Auto scaling and
Amazon ec2 features to scale when needed
to secure all Communications between the
databases in your data center and
application servers in the cloud you can
set up an Internet Protocol security or
IPS EC VPN connection between them
VPC with a private subnet only and
Hardware VPN access allows leveraging
the infrastructure of AWS without
exposing your network to the World Wide
Web it also facilitates expanding your
data center into the AWS cloud
with this topology it is possible to
introduce more web servers move business
applications to the cloud and increase
the Computing capacity by associating
the network with your VPC
by hosting your VPC behind the business
firewall you can effortlessly move the
it resources into the cloud without
modifying how the end users can access
them
let's see the steps to create an Amazon
VPC
under the networking Services click VPC
to display the Amazon VPC console
before we create or access an Amazon VPC
it is important to note that if your AWS
account was created after December 4th
2013 there is already a default VPC
assigned to your account
such accounts with a default VPC support
only the ec2 VPC platform
additionally there are restrictions to
the number of VPC components such as
security groups and routing tables that
you can set up
if you wish to increase these limits you
can request for the same
in the console dashboard click Start VPC
wizard to display the page select a VPC
configuration
it is important to note that this is the
first out of the four steps to create an
Amazon VPC
here click select to create your VPC
the page for the Second Step VPC with a
single public subnet is displayed it
shows default configuration setting
if you wish you can modify the
configuration settings
ipcidr block shows the IP address range
for your VPC
here enter the VPC name as vpc-1
the public subnet field shows the IP
address range for the subnet
the availability zone list allows you to
select the availability Zone where you
need to create the subnet
for this demonstration we will select no
preference this way AWS automatically
assigns an availability Zone
in the add endpoints for S3 to your
subnet section select a subnet that will
create a VPC endpoint for your Amazon S3
bucket in the same region
for this demonstration we will select
the option as none
then set the enable DNS host names
option to yes
this will ensure that instances launched
onto your VPC receive a DNS hostname
next the hardware tenancy option enables
you to select whether instances launched
into your VPC run on shared or dedicated
Hardware
for this demonstration we will keep it
as default
next click create VPC to display a
status window
in this window once your work is
completed click ok to close the status
window
congratulations you have successfully
created an Amazon VPC all right so in an
interview you would find yourself with a
question that might ask you define and
explain the three basic types of cloud
services and the AWS products that are
built based on them see here it's a very
straightforward question just explain
three basic types of cloud service and
when we talk about basic type of cloud
service it's compute obviously that's a
very basic service storage obviously
because you need to store your data
somewhere and networking that actually
connects a couple of other services to
your application this basic will not
include monitoring these basic will not
include analytics because they are
considered as optional they are
considered as Advanced Services you
could choose a non-cloud service or a
product for monitoring of and for
analytics so they're not considered as
basic so when we talk about Basics they
are compute storage and networking and
the second part of the questions is
explain some of the AWS products that
are built based on them of course
compute ec2 is a major one that's that's
the major share of the compute resource
and then we have platform as a service
which is elastic bean stock and then
function as a service which is Lambda
Auto scaling and light cell are also
part of compute services so the compute
domain it really helps us to run any
application and the compute service
helps us in managing the scaling and
deployment of an application again
Lambda is a compute service so the
compute service also helps in running
event initiated stateless applications
the next one was storage a lot of
emphasis is on storage these days
because if there's one thing that grows
in a network on a daily basis that
storage every new day we have new data
to store is manage so the storage is
again a basic and an important cloud
service and the products that are built
based on the storage services are S3
object storage Glacier for archiving EBS
elastic block storage as a drive
attachment for the ec2 instances and the
EFS file share for the ec2 instances so
the storage domain helps in the
following aspects it holds all the
information that the application uses so
it's the application data and we can
also archive old data using storage
which would be Glacier and any object
files and any requirement for Block
storage can be met through elastic Block
store and S3 which is again an object
storage talking about networks it's just
not important to answer the question
with the name of the services and the
name of the product it'll also be good
if you could go in depth and explain how
they can be used right so that actually
proves you to be a person knowledgeable
enough in that particular service or
product so talking about networking
domain VPC networking can't imagine
networking without VPC in in the cloud
environment especially in AWS Cloud
environment and then we have Route 53
for domain resolution or for DNS and
then we have cloudfront which is an edge
caching service that helps customers get
our customers to read their application
with low latency so networking domain
helps with some of the following use
cases it controls and manages the
connectivity of the AWS services within
our account and we can also pick an IP
address range if you're a network
engineer or if you are somebody who
works in networks or are planning to
work a network you will soon realize the
importance of choosing your own IP
address for easy remembering so having
an option to have your own IP address in
the cloud owned Range of IP address in
the cloud it really helps really really
helps in Cloud networking the other
question that get asked would be the
difference between the availability Zone
and the region actually the question
generally gets asked so to test how well
you can actually differentiate and also
correlate the availability Zone and the
region relationship right so a region is
a separate geographic area like the
us2s1 I mean which represents not
California or the AP South which
represents Mumbai so regions are a
separate geographic area on the contrary
availability Zone resides inside the
region you shouldn't stop there you
should go further and explain about
availability zones and availability
zones are isolated from each other and
some of the services will replicate
themselves within the available T-Zone
so availability Zone does replication
within them but regions they don't
generally do replication between them
the other question you could be asked is
what is order scaling what do we
achieved by Auto scaling so in short
Auto scaling it helps us to
automatically provision and launch new
instances Whenever there is an demand it
not only helps us meeting the increasing
demand it also helps in reducing the
resource usage when there is low demand
so Auto scaling also allows us to
decrease the resources or resource
capacity as per the need of that
particular R now this helps business in
not worrying about putting more effort
in managing or continuously monitoring
the server to see if they have the
needed resource or not because Auto
scaling is gonna handle it for us so
business does not need to worry about it
and auto scaling is one big reason why
people would want to go and pick a cloud
service especially in AWS service the
ability to increase and Shrink based on
the need of that art that's how powerful
is auto scaling the other question you
could get asked is what's geo-targeting
in Cloud front now we know that
cloudfront is caching and it caches
content globally in the Amazon caching
service Global wide the whole point is
to provide users worldwide access to the
data from a very nearest server possible
that's the whole point in using or going
for cloudfront then what do you mean by
Geo targeting Geo targeting is showing
customer and specific content based on
language we can customize the content
based on what's popular in that place we
can actually customize the content the
URL is the same but we could actually
change the content a little bit not the
whole content otherwise it would be
dynamic but but we can change the
content a little bit a specific a file
or a picture or a particular Link in a
website and show customized content to
users who will be in different parts of
the globe so how does it happen
cloudfront will detect the country where
the viewers are located and it will
forward the country code to the origin
server and once the origin server gets
the specialized or a specific country
code it will change the content and it
will send to the caching server and it
get cached there forever and the user
gets to view a Content which is
personalized for them for the country
they are in the other question you could
get asked is the steps involved in using
cloud formation or creating a cloud
formation or a backing up an environment
within cloud formation template we all
know that if there is a template we can
simply run it and it Provisions the
environment but there is a lot more
going into it so the first step in
moving towards infrastructure as a code
is to create the cloud formation
template which as of now supports Json
and yaml file format so first create the
cloud formation template and then save
the code in an X3 bucket S3 bucket
serves as the repository for our code
and then from the cloud formation call
the file in the S3 bucket and create a
stack and now cloud formation uses the
file reads the file understands services
that are being called understands the
order understands how they are connected
with each other cloud formation is
actually an intelligent service it
understands the relation based on the
code it would understand the
relationship between the different
services and it would set an order for
itself and then would provision the
services one after the other let's say a
service has a dependency and the
dependent service the other service
which This Server let's say it serves A
and B service B is dependent on service
a let's say cloud formation is an
intelligent service it would provision
the resource a first and then would
provision resource B what happens if we
inverse the order if we inverse the
order resource B first gets provision
and because it does not have dependency
chances that the cloud formation's
default behavior is that if something is
not provisioned properly if something is
not healthy it would roll back chances
that the environment provisioning will
roll back so to avoid that cloud
formation first Provisions all the
services that has or that's dependent on
that's depended by another service so it
Provisions those service first and then
Provisions the services that has
dependencies and if you are being hired
for a devops or you know if the
interviewer wanted to test your skill on
systems aside this definitely would be a
question in his list how do you upgrade
or downgrade a system with near zero
downtime now everybody is moving towards
zero downtime or near zero downtime all
of them want their application to be
highly available so the question would
be how do you actually upgrade or
downgrade a system with near zero
downtime now we all know that I can
upgrade an ec2 instance to a better ec2
instance by changing the instance type
stopping and starting but stopping and
starting is gonna cause a downtime right
so that's you should be answering or you
shouldn't be thinking in those terms
because that's the wrong answer
specifically the interviewer wants to
know how do you upgrade a system with
zero downtime so upgrading system with
zero downtime it includes launching
another system parallelly with the
bigger ec2 instance type over the bigger
capacity and install all that's needed
if you are going to use an Ami of the
old machine well and good you don't have
to go through installing all the updates
and installing all the application from
the Ami once you have launched it in a
bigger instance locally test the
application to see if it is working
don't put it on production yet test the
application to see if it is working and
if the application works we can actually
swap if your server is behind and behind
a Route 53 let's say all that you could
do is go to Route 53 update the
information with the new IP address new
IP address of the new server and that's
going to send traffic to the new server
now so the cutover is handled or if
you're using static IP you can actually
remove the static IP from the old
machine and assign it to the new machine
that's one way of doing it or if you are
using elastic Nik card you can actually
remove any card from the old machine and
attach the new cards to the new machine
so that way we would get near zero
downtime if you are hired for an
architect level you should be worrying
about cost as well along with the
technology and this question would test
how well you manage cost so what are the
tools and techniques we can use in AWS
to identify and correct identify and
know that we are paying the correct
amount for the resources that we are
using or how do you get a visibility of
your AWS resources running one way is to
check the building there's a place where
you can check the top services that were
utilized it could be free and it could
be paid Service as well top services
that can be utilized it's actually in
the dashboard of the cost Management
console so that table here shows the top
five most used services so looking at it
you can get it all right so I'm using a
lot of storage I'm using a lot of ec2
why is storage high you can go and try
to justify that and you will find if you
are storing things that shouldn't be
storing then clean it up why is compute
capacity so high why is data transfer so
high so if you start thinking in those
levels you'll be able to dig in and
clean up unnecessary and be able to save
your bill and there are cost Explorer
services available which will help you
to view your usage pattern or view your
spending for the past 13 months or so
and it will also forecast for the next
three months now how much will you be
using if your pattern is like this so
that will actually help and will give
you a visibility on how much you have
spent how much you will be spending if
the trend continues budgets are another
excellent a way to control cost you can
actually set up budget online this is
how much I am willing to spend for this
application for this team or for this
month for this particular resource so
you can actually put a budget Mark and
anytime it exceeds anytime it's nearing
you would get an alarm saying that well
we're about to reach the allocated
budget amount stuff like that that way
you can go back and know and you know
that how much the bill is going to be
for that month or you can take steps to
control bill amount for that particular
month so AWS budget is another very good
tool that you could use cost allocation
tags helps in identifying which team or
which resource has spent more in that
particular month instead of looking at
the bill as one list with no
specifications into it and looking at it
as an expenditure list you can actually
break it down and tag the expenditure to
the teams with cost allocation tags the
dev team has spent so much the
production team has spent so much the
training team has spent more than the
dev and the production team why is that
you'll be able to you know think in
those levels only if you have cost
allocation tags now cost allocation tags
are nothing but the tags that you would
put when you create a resource so for
Production Services you would put as a
production that you would create a
production tag and you would associate
that resources to it and at a later
point when you actually pull up your
bill that's going to show a detailed a
list of this is the owner this is the
group and this is how much they have
used in the last month and you can move
forward with your investigation and
encourage or stop users using more
services with the cost allocation tax
the other famous question is are there
any other tools or is there any other
way of accessing AWS results other than
the console console is GUI right so in
other words other than GUI how would you
use the AWS resource and how familiar
are you with those tools and
Technologies the other tools that are
available that we can leverage and
access the AWS resource are of course
footy you can configure Puri to access
the AWS resources like log into an ec2
instance an ec2 instance does not always
have to be logged in through the console
you could use putty to log into an ec2
instance and like the jump box like the
proxy machine and like the Gateway
machine and from there you can actually
access the rest of the resources so this
is an alternative to the console and of
course we have the AWS CLI in any of the
Linux machines or Windows machines we
can install so that's 0.23 and 4 we can
install AWS CLI for Linux Windows also
for Mac so we can install them and from
there from your local machine we can
access run AWS commands and access
provision monitor the AWS resources the
other ones are we can access the AWS
resource programmatically using AWS SDK
and Eclipse so these are a bunch of
options we have to use the AWS resource
other than the console if you are
interviewed in a company or buy a
company that focuses more on security
and want to use AWS native services for
their security then you will come across
this question what services can be used
to create a centralized logging solution
the basic Services we could use are
cloudwatch logs store them in S3 and
then use elasticsearch to visualize them
and use Kinesis to move the data from S3
to elasticsearch right so log management
it actually helps organizations to track
the relationship between operational and
security changes and the events that got
triggered based on those logs instead of
logging into an instance or instead of
logging into the environment and
checking the resources physically I can
come to a fair conclusion by just
looking at the logs every time there's a
change the system would scream and it
gets tracked in the cloud watch and then
Cloud watch pushes it to S3 Kinesis
pushes the data from S3 to elasticsearch
and I can do a time-based filter and I
would get an a fair understanding of
what was going on in the environment for
the past one hour or whatever the time
window that I wanted to look at so it
helps in getting a good understanding of
the infrastructure as a whole all the
logs are getting saved in one place so
all the infrastructure logs are getting
saved in one place so it's easy for me
to look at it in an infrastructure
perspective so we know the services that
can be used and here are some of the
services and how they actually connect
to each other it could be logs that
belongs to One account it could be logs
that belongs to multiple accounts it
doesn't matter you know those three
services are going to work fairly good
and they're gonna inject or they're
gonna like suck logs from the other
accounts put it in one place and help us
to monitor so as you see you have Cloud
watch here that actually tracks the
metrics you can also use cloud trail if
you want to log API calls as well push
them in an S3 back kit so there are
different types of logs flow logs are
getting captured in an instance
application logs are getting captured
from the same VPC from a different VPC
from the same account from a different
account and all of them are analyzed
using elasticsearch using the kibana
client so step one is to deploy the ECS
cluster step two is to restrict access
to the ECS cluster because it's valid
data you don't want anybody to put their
hands and access their data so restrict
access to the ECS dashboard and we could
use Lambda also to push the data from
cloud watch to The elasticsearch Domain
and then kibana is actually the
graphical tool that helps us to
visualize the logs instead of looking at
log as just statements or a bunch of
characters a bunch of files kibana helps
us to analyze the logs in a graphical or
a chart or a bar diagram format again in
an interview the interview is more
concerned about testing your knowledge
on AWS security products especially on
the logging monitoring even management
or Incident Management then you could
have a question like this what are the
native AWS security logging capabilities
now most of the services have their own
logging in them like have their own
logging like S3 S3 has its own login and
cloudfront has its own logging DS has
its own logging VPC has its own logging
in additional there are account level
logins like a cloudtrail and AWS config
services so there are a variety of
logging options available in the AWS
like Cloud soil config cloudfront
redshift logging RDS logging VPC flow
logs S3 object logging S3 access logging
stuff like that so we're going to look
at two servers in specified cloudtrail
now this cloud trail the very first
product in that picture we just saw are
the cloud trail provides an very high
level history of the API calls for all
the account and with that we can
actually perform a very good security
analysis a security analysis of our
account and these logs are actually
delivered to you can configure it they
can be delivered to S3 for long time
archivals and based on a particular
event it can also send an email
notification to us saying hey just got
this error thought I'll let you know
stuff like that the other one is config
service now config service helps us to
understand the configuration changes
that happened in our environment and we
can also set up notifications based on
the configuration changes so it records
the cumulative changes that are made in
a short period of time so if you want to
go through the lifetime of a particular
resource what are the things that happen
what are the things it went through they
can be looked at using aw us config all
right the other question you could get
asked is if you know your role includes
taking care of cloud security as well
then the other question you could get
asked is the native services that Amazon
provides automaticate DDOS which is
denial of service now not all companies
would go with Amazon native services but
there are some companies which want to
stick with Amazon native Services just
to save them from the headache of
managing the other softwares or bringing
in another tool a third-party tool into
managing DDOS they simply want to stick
with Amazon proprietary Amazon native
services and a lot of companies are
using Amazon service to prevent DDOS
denial of service now denial of service
is if you already know what denial of
service is well and good if you do not
know then let's know it now denial of
service is a user trying to or
maliciously making attempt to access a
website or an application the user would
actually create multiple sessions and he
would occupy all the sessions and he
would not let legimate users access the
servers so he's in turn denying the
service for the user a quick picture
review of what denial of services now
look at it these users instead of making
one connection they are making multiple
connections and there are cheap software
programs available that would actually
trigger connections from different
computers in the internet with different
Mac addresses so everything kind of
looks legimate for the server and it
would accept those connections and it
would keep the sessions open the actual
users won't be able to use them so
that's denying the service for the
actual users denial of service all right
and distributed denial of service is
generating attacks from multiple places
you know from a distributed environment
so that's distributed denial of service
so the tools the native tools that helps
us to provide event the denial of
service attacks in AWS is cloud shield
and web access firewall AWS web now they
are the major ones they are designed to
mitigate a denial of service if your
website is often bothered by denial of
service then we should be using AWS
Shield or AWS Waf and there are a couple
of other tools that all showed us when I
say that also does denial of service is
not their primary job but you could use
them for denial of service route 53's
purpose is to provide DNS cloudfront is
to provide caching elastic load balancer
elb's work is to provide load balancing
VPC is to create and secure a virtual
private environment but they also
support mitigating denial of service but
not to the extent you would get in AWS
shield and AWS web so AWS shield and Waf
are the primary ones but the rest can
also be used to mitigate distributed
denial of service the other tricky
question is this actually will test your
familiarity with the region and the
services available in the region so when
you're trying to provision a service in
a particular region you're not seeing
the service in that region how do we go
about fixing it or how do we go about
using the service in the cloud it's a
tricky question and if you have not gone
through such situation you can totally
blow it away you really need to have a
good understanding on regions the
services available in those regions and
what a particular service is not
available how to go about doing it the
answer is not all services are available
in all regions anytime Amazon announces
a new service they don't immediately
publish them on all regions they start
small and as in when the traffic
increases as and when it becomes more
likeable to the customers they actually
move the service to different regions so
as you see in this picture within
America North Virginia has is more
services compared to Ohio or Compared to
North California So within not America
itself North Virginia is the preferred
one so similarly there are preferred
regions within Europe Middle East and
Africa and prefer regions within Asia
Pacific so anytime we don't see a
service in a particular region chances
that the service is not available in
that region yet we got to check the
documentation and find the nearest
region that offers that service and
start using the service from that region
now you might think well if I'm looking
for a service in Asia let's say in
Mumbai and if it is not available why
not simply switch to North Virginia and
start using it you could but you know
that's going to add more latency to your
application so that's why we need to
check for application which is check for
region which is very near to the place
where you want to serve your customers
and find nearest region instead of
always going back to North Virginia and
deploying an application in North
Virginia again let's as you place
there's a link in aws.com that you can
go and look for services available in
different region and that's exactly what
you're seeing here and if your service
is not available in a particular region
switch to the other region that provides
your service the nearest other region
that provides that service and start
using service from there with the coming
up of cloud a lot of companies have
turned down their monitoring team
instead they want to go with the
monitorings that cloud provides you know
nobody wants to or at least many people
don't want to go through the hassle of
at least new startups and new companies
that are thinking of having a monitoring
environment that they don't want to go
with traditional knock monitoring
instead they would like to leverage AWS
monitorings available because it
monitors a lot of stuff not just the
availability but it monitors a lot of
stuff like failures errors it also
triggers emails stuff like that so how
do you actually set up a monitor to
website how to set up a Monitor to
Monitor the website metrics in real time
in AWS the simple way anytime you have a
question about monitoring cloudwatch
should strike your mind because
cloudwatch is meant for monitoring is
meant for collecting metrics is is meant
for providing graphical representation
of what's going on in a particular
Network at a particular point of time so
Cloud watch cloudwatch helps us to
monitor applications and using
cloudwatch we can monitor the state
changes not only the state changes the
auto scaling life cycle events anytime
there are more services added there is a
reduction in the number of servers
because of less usage a very informative
messages can be received through
cloudwatch any cloudwatch can now
support scheduled events if you want to
schedule anything cloudwatch has an
event that would schedule an action
right schedule a Trigger Time based not
incident based you know anything
happening and then you get an action
happening that's incident based on the
other hand you can simply schedule few
things on time based so that's possible
with Cloud watch So This Cloud watch
integrates very well with a lot of other
services like notifications for
notifying the user or for notifying the
administrator about it and it can
integrate well with Lambda so to trigger
an action anytime you're designing an
auto healing environment This Cloud
watch can actually monitor and send an
email if we are integrating it with SNS
simple notification service or this
Cloud watch can monitor and based on
what's Happening it can trigger an event
in Lambda and that would in turn run a
function till the environment comes back
to normal so cloudwatch integrates well
with a lot of other AWS Services all
right so cloudwatch has three statuses
green when everything is going good
hello when the service is degraded and
red when the service is not available
green is good so we don't have to do
anything about it but anytime there is
an Lo the picture that we're looking at
it's actually calling an Lambda function
to debug the application and to fix it
and anytime there's a red alert it
immediately notifies the owner of the
application about well this service is
down and here is the report that I have
here is the metrics that I've collected
about the service stuff like that if the
job role requires you to manage the
servers as well there are certain job
roles which are on the system side there
are certain job roles which is
development plus system side now you're
responsible for the application and the
server as well so if that's the case you
might be tested with some basic
questions like the different types of
virtualization in AWS and what are the
difference between them all right the
three major types of virtualization are
hvm which is Hardware virtual machine
the other one is PV para virtualization
and the third one is PV on hvm para
virtualization on Hardware virtual
module all right the difference between
them are actually describing them is
actually the difference between them hvm
it's actually a fully virtualized
Hardware you know the whole Hardware is
virtualized and all virtual machines act
separate from each other and these VMS
are booted by executing Master boot
record in the root block and when we
talk about para virtualization paragraph
is actually the special boot loader
which boots the PV Amis and when we talk
about PV on hvm it's it's actually the
marriage between hvm and PV and this
para virtualization on hvm in other
words PV on hvm it actually helps
operating system take advantage in
storage and the network input output
available through the host another good
question is name some of the services
that are not region specific now you've
been thought that all services are
within a region and some services are
within an availability zone for example
ec2 is within an availability Zone EBS
is within an availability Zone S3 is is
region specific dynamodb is region
specific stuff like that VPC is both
availability and region specific meaning
you know subnets are availability Zone
specific and vpcs region specific stuff
like that so you might have thought you
might have learned in that combination
but there could be some tricky questions
that tests you how well you have
understood the region non-region and
availability non-availability Services I
should say there are services that are
not region specific that would be IAM so
we can't have IAM for every availability
Zone and for every region which means
you know users will have to use one
username and password for one region and
anytime they switch to another region
they will have to use another username
and password that that's more work and
that's not a good design as well
authentication has to be Global so IM is
a global Service and which means it's
not region specific on the other hand
Route 53 is again a regional Pacific so
we can't have a Route 53 for every
region Route 53 is not a region specific
service it's a global Service and it's
one application users access from
everywhere or from every part of the
world so we can't have one URL or one
DNS name for each region if your
application is a global application and
then web application firewall works well
with cloudfront then cloudfront is a
region based service so the web
application firewall it's not region
specific service it's a global Service
and cloudfront is again a global Service
though you can you know cache content on
a continent and country basis it's still
considered a global Service all right
it's not bound to any region so when you
activate cloudfront you're activating it
away from region or availability zone so
when you're activating a web application
firewall because it's not a region
specific service you're activating it
away from availability Zone and regions
so a quick recap I am users groups roles
and accounts they are Global Services
they can be used globally around 53
services are offered at Edge locations
and they are Global as well web
application firewall a service that
protects our web application from common
web exploits they are Global Services
well Cloud front Cloud front is global
content delivery Network CDN and they
are offered at Edge locations which are
a global Service in other words
non-region specific service or Beyond
region service all right this is another
good question as well in the project
that you are being interviewed if they
really want to secure their environment
using Nat or if they are already
securing their environment using Nat by
any of these two methods like Nat
Gateway or Nat instances you can expect
this question what are the difference
between a Nat Gateway and Nat instances
now they both saw the same thing right
so they're not two different Services
trying to achieve two different things
they both serve the same thing but still
they do have differences in them all
right on a high level they both achieve
providing nothing for the service behind
it but the difference comes when we talk
about the availability of it not Gateway
is a managed service by Amazon whereas
Nat instance is managed by us now I'm
talking about the third Point
maintenance here not Gateway is managed
by Amazon that instance is managed by us
and availability of nat Gateway is very
high and availability of nat instance is
less compared to the NAT Gateway because
it's managed by us you know it's on an
ec2 instance which could actually fail
and if it fails we'll have to relaunch
it but if it is not Gateway if something
happens to that service Amazon would
take care of reprovisioning it and
talking about bandwidth it can burst up
to 75 gigabits now traffic through the
nag Gateway can burst up to 75 gigabits
but for that instance it actually
depends on the server that we launch and
if we are launching a T2 micro it barely
gets any bandwidth so there's a
difference there and the performance
because it's highly available because of
the bigger pipe 75 gigabits now the
performance of the NAT Gateway is very
high but the performance of the NAD
instance is going to be average again it
depends on the size of the NAT instance
that we pick and billing a billing for
Nat Gateway is the number of gateways
that we provision and the duration for
which we use the NAT Gateway but billing
for Nat instance is number of instance
and the type of instance that we use of
course number of instance duration and
the type of instance that we use
Security in that Gateway cannot be
assigned meaning it already comes with
full backed security but but in that
instance security is a bit customizable
I can go and change the security because
such a server managed by me or managed
by us I can always change the security
well allow this allow don't allow this
stuff like that size and load of the NAT
Gateway is uniform but the size and the
load of the NAT instance changes as per
around Gateway is a Fix-It product but
in that instance can be small instance
can be a big instance so the size and
the load through it varies
right the other question you could get
asked is what are the difference between
stopping and terminating an ec2 instance
now you will be able to answer only if
you have worked on environments where
you have your instance stopped and where
you have your instance terminated if you
have only used lab and are attending the
interview chances are that you might you
always lost when answering this question
it might look like both are the same
well stopping and terminating both are
the same but there is a difference in it
so when you stop an instance it actually
performs a normal shutdown on the
instance and it simply moves the
instance to the stop state but when you
actually terminate the instance the
instance is moved to this stop State the
EBS volumes that are attached to it are
deleted and removed and will never be
able to recover them again so that's a
big difference between stopping and
terminating an instance if you're
thinking of using the instance again
along with the data in it you should
only be thinking of stopping the
instance but you should be terminating
the instance only if you want to get rid
of that instance forever
if you are being interviewed for an
architect level position or a junior
architect level position or even an
Cloud consultant level position or even
in an engineering position this is a
very common question that get asked what
are the different types of easy to
instances based on their cost or based
on how we pay them right they're all
compute capacity for example the
different types are on the balance
tenses pod instances and reserved
instances it kind of looks the same they
all provide the compute capacity they
all provide the same type of Hardwares
for us but if you are looking at Cost
saving or optimizing cost in our
environment we're going to be very
careful about which one are we picking
now we might think that well I'll go
with on-demand instance because I pay on
a per hour basis which is cheap you know
I can use them anytime I want and
anytime I don't want I can simply get
rid of it by terminating it you're right
but if the requirement is to use the
service for one year the requirement is
to use the service for three years then
you'll be wasting a lot of money buying
on-demand instances you'll be wasting a
lot of money paying on an hourly basis
instead we should be going for reserved
instance where we can reserve the
capacity for the complete one year or
complete three years and save huge
amount in buying reserved instances
alright so on-demand is cheap to start
with if you are only planning to use it
for a short while but if you're planning
to run it for a long while then we
should be going for reserved instance
that is what is cost efficient so spot
instance is cheaper than on-demand
instance and there are different use
cases for spot instance as well so let's
look at one after the other the
on-demand instance the on-demand
instance is purchased at a fixed rate
per hour this is very short term and
irregular workloads and for testing for
development on demand instance is a very
good use case we should be using
on-demand for production Spartan
instance spot instance allows users to
purchase ec2 at a reduced price and
anytime we have more instances we can
always go and sell it in spot instances
I'm referring to anytime we have more
reserved instances we can always sell
them in spot instance catalog and the
way we buy Spot instance is we actually
put a budget this is how much I'm
willing to pay all right would you be
able to give service within this cost so
anytime the price comes down and meets
the cost that we have put in will be
assigned an instance and anytime the
price shoots up the instance will be
taken away from us but in case of
on-demand instances we have bought that
instance for that particular R and it
stays with us but with spot instances it
varies based on the price if you meet
the price you get the instance if you
don't meet the price it goes away to
somebody else and the spot instance
availability is actually based on supply
and demand in the market there's no
guarantee that you will get support
instance at all time all right so that's
a caveat there you should be familiar
with that's a caveat there you should be
aware when you are proposing somebody
that we can go for spot instance and
save money it's not always going to be
available if you want your spot instance
to be available to you then we need to
carefully watch the history of the price
of the spot instance now how much was it
last month and how much was it how much
is it this month so how can I code or
how much can I code stuff like that so
you got to look at those history before
you propose somebody that well we're
gonna save money using spot instance on
the other hand reserved instance provide
cost savings for the company or we can
opt for reserved instances for you know
one year or three years there are
actually three types of reserved
instances light medium and heavy
reserved instances they are based on the
amount that we would be paying and cost
benefit also depends with reserved
instance the cost benefit also depends
based on are we doing all upfront or no
upfront or partial payment then split
the rest as monthly payments so there
are many purchase options available but
overall if you're looking at using an
application for the next one year and
three years you should not be going for
on-demand instance you should be going
for reserved instance and that's what
gives you the cost benefit
and in an AWS interview sometimes you
might be asked you know how you interact
with the AWS environment are you using
CLI are you using console and depending
on your answer whether console or a CLI
the panelist put a score okay this
person is CLI specific this person is
console specific or this person has used
AWS environment through the SDK stuff
like that so this question tests whether
you are a CLI person or an a console
person and the question goes like this
how do you set up SSH agent forwarding
so that you do not have to copy the key
every time you log in if you have used
Puri anytime if you want to log into an
ec2 instance you will have to put the IP
and the port number along with that you
will have to map or we will have to map
the key in the Puri and this has to be
done every time that's what we would
have done in our lab environments right
but in production environment using the
same key or mapping the same key again
and again every time it's actually a
hassle it's considered as a blocker so
you might want to Cache it you might
want to permanently add it in your putty
session so you can immediately log in
and start using it so here in the place
where you would actually map the private
key there's a quick button that actually
fixes or that actually binds your SSH to
your pretty instance so we can enable
SSH agent forwarding and that will
actually bind our key to the SSH and
next time when we try to log in we don't
have to always go through mapping the
key and trying to log in all right this
question what are Solaris and ax
operating systems are they available
with AWS that question generally gets
asked to test how familiar are you with
the Amis available how familiar are you
with ec2 how familiar are you with the
ec2 Hardwares available that basically
tests that now the first question or the
first thought that comes to your mind is
well everything is available with AWS
I've seen Windows I've seen Ubuntu I've
seen Red Hat I've seen Amazon Amis and
if I don't see my operating system there
I can always go to Marketplace and try
them if I don't final Marketplace I can
always go to community and try them so a
lot of Amis available there are a lot of
operating systems available I will be
able to find Solaris and ax but that's
not the case Solaris and ax are not
available with AWS that's because
Solaris uses a different I mean Solaris
does not support the architecture does
not support public Cloud currently the
same goes for ax as well they run on
power CPU and not on Intel and as of now
Amazon does not provide Power machines
this should not be confused with HPC
which is a high performance Computing
should not be confused with that now
these are different Hardwares different
CPU itself that the cloud providers did
do not provide yet another question you
could get asked in organizations that
would want to automate the their
infrastructure using Amazon native
Services would be how do you actually
recover an ec2 instance or Auto recover
an ec2 instance when it fails oh well we
know that ec2 instances are considered
as immutable meaning irreparable we
don't spend time fixing bugs in an OS
stuff like that you know once an ec2
instance crashes like it goes on a over
spanic or there are various reasons why
it would fail so we don't have to really
worry about fixing it we can always
relaunch that instance and that would
fix it but what if it happens at two
o'clock in the night what if it happens
that during a weekend when nobody is in
office now looking or monitoring those
instances so you would want to automate
that not only on a weekend or during
midnights but it's general practice good
to automate it so you could face this
question how do you actually automate an
ec2 instance once it fails and the
answer to that question is using Cloud
watch we can recover the instance so as
you see there is an alarm threshold a
set in Cloud watch and once the
threshold is met meaning if there is an
error if there is a failure if the ec2
instance is not responding for a certain
while we can set an alarm and once the
alarm is met let's say the CPU
utilization stayed high for 5 minutes
right it's not taking any new
connections or the instance is not
pinging for five minutes or in this case
it's two minutes it's not pinging so
it's not going to respond connection so
in those cases you would want to
automatically recover that ec2 instance
by rebooting the instance all right now
look at this the take this action
section under the action so there we
have a bunch of options like recover
this instance meaning reboot the
instance so that's how we would recover
the other two options are beyond the
scope of the question but still you can
go ahead and apply just like I'm gonna
do it so the other option to stop the
instance that's very useful when you
want to stop instances that are having
low utilizations nobody is using the
system as of now you don't want them to
be running and wasting the cloud
expenditure so you can actually set an
alarm that stops the ec2 instance that's
having low utilization so somebody was
working in an instance and they left it
without or they forgot to shut down that
instance and it gets I mean they will
only use it again the next day morning
so in between there could be like 12
hours that the system is running idle
nobody is using it and you're paying for
it so you can identify such instances
and actually stop them when the CPU
utilization is low meaning nobody is
using it the other one is to terminate
let's say you want to give system to
somebody temporarily and you don't want
them to hand the system back to you all
right this is actually an idea in other
words this is actually the scenario so
you hand over a system to somebody and
when they're done they're done we can
actually terminate the system so you
could instruct the other person to
terminate the system when they're done
and they could forget and the instance
could be running forever or you can
monitor the system after the specified
time is over and you can terminate the
system or best part you can automate the
system termination so you assign a
system to somebody and then turn on this
cloudwatch action to terminate the
instance when the CPU is low for like
two hours meaning they've already left
or CPU is low for 30 minutes meaning
they've already left stuff like that so
that's possible and if you're getting
hired for an system side architect or
even on the sysop site you could face
this question what are the common and
different types of Ami designs there are
a lot of AMR designs the question is the
common ones and the difference between
them so the common ones are the full
back Amis and the other one is just
enough OS Ami je OS Ami and the other
one is hybrid type Amis so let's look at
the difference between them the full
backed Ami just like the name says it's
fully baked it's ready to use Ami and
this is the simplest Ami to deploy can
be a bit expensive it can be a bit a
cumbersome because you'll have to do a
lot of work beforehand you could use the
Amis a lot of planning a lot of thought
process will go into it and the Ami is
ready to use right you hand over the Ami
to somebody and it's ready to use or if
you want to reuse the Ami it's already
ready for you to use so that's full
baked Ami the other one is just enough
operating system Ami just like the name
says it has I mean as you can also see
in the diagram or in the picture it
covers a part of the OS all bootstraps
are already packed properly and the
security monitoring logging and the
other stuff are configured at the time
of deployment or at the time you would
be using it so not much thought process
will go in here the only focus is on
choosing the operating system and what
goes the operating system specific
agents or bootstraps that goes into the
operating system that's all we worry
about the advantage of this is it's
flexible meaning you can choose to
install additional softwares at the time
of deploying but that's going to require
an additional expertise on the person
who will be using the Ami so that's
another overhead there but the advantage
is that it's kind of flexible I can
change the configurations during the
time of deployment the other one is a
hybrid Ami now the hybrid Ami actually
falls in between the fully baked Ami and
just enough operating system options so
these Amis have some features of the big
type and some features of the just
enough OS type so as you see the
security monitoring logging are packed
in that Ami and the runtime environments
or insta stalled during the time of a
deployment so this is where the strict
company policies would go into the Ami
company policies like you got to lock
this you got to monitor this these are
the ports that generally gets open in
all the systems stuff like that so they
strictly go into the Ami and sits in an
AMF format and during deployment you
have the flexibility of choosing the
different runtime and the application
that sits in an ec2 instance another
very famous question you would face in
an interview is how can you recover
login to an ec2 instance to which you
lost the key well we know that if the
key is lost we can't recover it there
are some organizations that integrate
their ec2 instances with an ad that's
different all right so you can go and
reset the password in the ad and you
will be able to log into the new
password but here this specific tricky
question is you are using a key to log
in and how do you recover if you have
lost the key generally companies would
have made a backup of the key so we can
pick from the backup but here the
specific question is we have lost the
key literally no backups on the key at
all so how can we log in and we know
that we can't log into the instance
without the key present with us so the
steps to recover is that make the
instance use another key and use that
key to log in once the key is lost it's
lost forever we won't be able to recover
it you can't raise a ticket with Amazon
not possible they're not going to help
it's beyond the scope so make the
instance use another key it's only the
key that's the problem you still have
valid data in it you got to recover the
data it's just a key that's having the
problem so we can actually focus on the
key part alone and change the key and
that will allow us to log in so how do
we do it step by step procedure so first
verify the ec2 config service is running
in that instance if you want you can
actually beforehand install the ec2
config in that service or you can
actually make the easy to config run
through the console just couple of
button clicks and that will make the
easy to configure one in that easy to do
instance and then it detach the root
volume for that instance of course it's
going to require a stop and start to
detach the root volume from the instance
attach the root volume to another
instance as a temporary volume or it
could be a temporary instance that
you've launched only to fix this issue
and then login to that instance and to
that particular volume and modify the
configuration file configuration file
modify it to use the new key and then
move the root volume back to its
original position and restart the
instance and now the instance is going
to have the new key and you also have
the new key with which you can log in so
that's how we go ahead and fix it now
let's move on to some product specific
or S3 product specific questions a
general perception is S3 and EBS can be
used interchangeably and the interviewer
would want to test your knowledge on S3
and EVS well EBS uses S3 that's true but
they can't be interchangeably used so
you might face this question what are
some key differences between AWS S3 and
EBS well the differences are S3 is an
object store meaning you can't install
anything in it you can store drive files
but you can't actually install in it
it's not a file system but ABS is a file
system you can install Services I mean
install applications in it and that's
going to run stuff like that and talking
about performance S3 is much faster and
abs is super faster when accessing from
the instance because from the instance
if you need to access S3 you'll actually
have to go out through the internet and
access the S3 or S3 is an external
service very external service you'll
have to go through or you'll have to go
outside of your VPC to access S3 S3 does
not come under a VPC but EBS comes under
a VPC it's on the same VPC so you would
be able to use it kind of locally
compared to S3 EBS is very local so that
way it's going to be faster and
redundancy talking about redundancy of
S3 and abs S3 is a replicated the data
in S3 is replicated across the data
centers but EBS is replicated within the
data center meaning S3 is replicated
across availability zones EBS is within
an availability zone so that way
redundancy is a bit less in ABS in other
words plural NC is higher in S3 than EPs
and talking about security of S3 is3 can
be made private as well as public
meaning anybody can access S3 from
anywhere in the internet that's possible
with S3 but EBS can only only be
accessed when attached to an ec2
instance right just one instance can
access it whereas S3 is publicly
directly accessible the other question
related to S3 security is how do you
allow access to a user to a certain a
user to a certain bucket which means
this user is not having access to S3 at
all but this user needs to be given
access to a certain bucket how do we do
it the same case applies to servers as
well in few cases there could be an
instance where a person is new to the
team and you actually don't want them to
access the production service now he is
in the production group and by default
he or she is granted access to that
server but you specifically want to deny
access to that production server till
the time he or she is matured enough to
access or understand the process
understand the do's and don'ts before
they can put their hands on the
production server so how do we go about
doing it so first we would categorize
our instances well these are critical
instances these are normal instances and
we were actually put a tag on them
that's how we categorize right so you
put a tag on them put attacks saying
well they are highly critical they are
medium critical and they are not
critical at all still there in
production stuff like that and then you
would pick the users who wants to or who
should be or should not be given access
to a certain server and you would
actually allow the user to access or not
access servers based on a specific tag
in other words you can use actually tags
in in the previous step we put tags on
the critical server right so you would
Define that this user is not going to
use this tag all right this user is not
allowed to use the resources for this
stack so that's how you would make your
step forward so you would allow or deny
based on the tags that you have put so
in this case he or she will not be
allowed to servers which are TAG
critical servers so that's how you allow
deny access to them the same goes for
bucket as well or if an organization is
excessively using S3 for their data
storage because of the benefit that it
provides the cost and the durability you
might get asked this question which is
organizations would replicate the data
from one region to another region for
additional data durability and for
having data redundancy not only for that
they would also do that for Dr purposes
for Disaster Recovery if the whole
region is down you still have the data
available somewhere else and you can
pick and use it some organizations would
store data in different regions for
compliance reasons to provide low
latency access to their users who are
local to that region stuff like that so
when companies do replication how do you
make sure that there is consistency in
the replication how do you make sure
that a replication is not failing and
the data gets transferred for sure and
there are logs for that replication this
is something that the companies would
use where they are excessively using S3
and they're fully relying on the
replication in running their business
and the way we could do it is we can set
up a replication monitor it's actually
set of tools that we could use together
to make sure that the cloud replication
a region level replication is happening
properly so this is how it happens now
on this side on the left hand side we
have the region one and on the right
hand side we have Region 2 and region 1
is the source bucket and region two is
the destination bucket all right so
object is put in the source bucket and
it has to go directly to the region to
bucket or made a copy in the region two
bucket and the problem is sometimes it
fails and there is no consistency
between them so the way you would do it
is connect these Services together and
create an cross replication or cross
region replication monitor that actually
monitors that actually monitors your
environment so there are cloudwatch that
make sure that the data is moved no data
is failing again there's Cloud watch on
the other end make sure that the data is
moving and then we have the logs
generated through cloudtrail and that's
actually written in dynamodb and if
there is an error if something is
failing you get notified through an SMS
or you get notified through an email
using the SNS service so that's how we
could leverage these tools and set up
and cross region replication monitor
that actually monitors your data
replication some common issues that
company companies face in VPC is that we
all know that I can use Route 53 to
resolve an IP address externally from
the internet but by default the servers
won't connect to the other servers using
our custom DNS name that it does not do
that by default so it's actually a
problem there are some additional things
that as an administrator or as an
architect or as a person who uses it you
will have to do and that's what we're
going to discuss so the question could
be a VPC is not resolving the server
through the DNS you can access it
through the IP but not through the DNS
name and what could be the issue and how
do you go about fixing it and you will
be able to answer this question only if
you have done it already it's a quick
and simple step by default all VPC does
not allow that's the default feature and
we will have to enable the DNS hostname
resolution before now this is for the
custom DNS not for the default DNS that
comes along this is for the custom DNS
so we will have to enable the DNS
hostname resolution so our will have to
enable DNS hostname resolution so they
actually resolve let's say I want to
connect to a server one dot
simplylearn.com by default it's not
allowed but if I enable this option then
I will be able to connect to server one
simplylearn.com if a company has vpcs in
different regions and they have a head
office in a central place and the rest
of them are Branch offices and they are
connecting to the head office for Access
or you know for saving data or for
accessing certain files or certain data
or touring data all right so they would
actually mimic The Hub and spoke
topology where you have the VPC which is
centrally in an accessible region a
centrally accessible region and then you
would have a local vpcs or Branch
offices in different other regions and
they get connected to the VPC in the
central location and the question is how
do you actually connect the multiple
sites to a VPC and make communication
happen between them by default it does
not do that we know that vpcs they need
to be paired between them in order to
access the resources let's look at this
picture right so I have like a customer
Network or Branch offices in different
parts and they get connected to a VPC
that's fine so what we have achieved is
those different offices the remote
offices they are connecting to the VPC
and they're talking but they can't
connect or they can't talk to each other
that's what we have built but the
requirement is the traffic needs to or
they should be able to talk to each
other but they should not have direct
connection between them which means that
they will have to come and hit the VPC
and then reach the other customer
Network which is in Los Angeles or which
is in New York right that's the
requirement so that's possible with some
architecting in the cloud so that's
using VPN Cloud Hub you look at this
dotted lines which actually allows
customers or which actually allows the
corporate networks to talk to each other
through the VPC Again by default it
doesn't happen Cloud Hub is an
architecture that we should be using to
make this happen and what's the
advantage of it as a central office or
as the headquarters office which is in
the VPC or headquarters data center
which is in the VPC you have control or
the VPC has control on who talks to who
and what traffic can talk to I mean what
traffic can be routed to the other head
office stuff like that that centralized
control is on the VPC the other question
you could get asked is name and explain
some security products and features
available in VPC well VPC itself is a
security service it provides security
service to the application but how do
you actually secure the VPC itself
that's the question and yes there are
products that can actually secure the
VPC or the VPC delivers those products
to secure the application access to the
vpcs restricted through a network access
control list all right so that's and
security product in VPC and a VPC has
security groups that protects the
instances from unwanted inbound and
outbound traffic and network access
control list protects the subnets from
unwanted inbound and outbound access and
there are flow logs we can capture in VP
scene that captures incoming and
outgoing traffic through a VPC which
will be used for later analysis as in
what's the traffic pattern what's the
behavior of the traffic pattern stuff
like that so there are some security
products and features available in VPC
now how do you monitor VPC VPC is a very
important concept very important Service
as well everything sits in a VPC most of
the service sits in a VPC except for
Lambda and S3 and dynamodb and couple of
other services most of them sit in a VPC
for security reasons so how do you
monitor your VPC how do you gain some
visibility on your VPC well we can gain
visibility on our VPC using VPC flow log
that's the basic Service as you see it
actually captures what's allowed what's
not allowed stuff like that which IP is
allowed which IP is not allowed stuff
like that so we can gather it and we can
use that for analysis and the other one
is cloud watch and Cloud watch logs the
data transfers that happen so this is
you know who gets allowed and who does
not get allowed I mean the flow logs is
who is allowed and who's not allowed
that kind of detail and Cloud watch
gives information about the data
transfer how much data is getting
transferred we can actually pick unusual
data transfers if there is a sudden hike
in the graph there's a sudden hike and
something happens at 12 on a regular
basis and you weren't expecting it
there's something suspicious it could be
valid backups it could be a malicious
activity as well so that's how you know
by looking at cloudwatch logs and
cloudwatch dashboard now let's talk
about multiple choice questions when
going for an interview you might
sometimes find yourself that the company
is conducting an online test based on
the score they can put you to a panelist
and then they would take it forward so
we thought it will also include multiple
choice questions to help you better
handle such situation if you come across
all right when you find yourself in such
situation and the key to clear them is
to understand the question properly read
between the lines that's what they say
in know there can be like a big
paragraph with three lines or ten lines
you really got to understand what the
question is about and then try to find
answer for that question so that's a
thumb rule number one and then the
second rule is try to compare and
contrast the services mentioned or try
to compare and contrast the answers you
can easily read out one or two answers
and then you will be left with only two
answers to decide from you know so that
also helps you with time and that's how
that also helps you with some Precision
in your answer so number one read
between the lines number two compare and
contrast the services and you'll be able
to easily read out the wrong ones so
let's try answering this question
suppose you are a game designer and you
want to develop a game with a single
digit millisecond latency which of the
following database Services would you
choose so we know that the following are
database services are good enough all
right and it talks about about
millisecond latency that's the key point
and the third thing is it's a game it
could be a mobile game it's a game that
you are trying to design and you need
the millisecond latency and it has to be
a database all right so let's talk about
the options available RDS RDS is a
database for sure is it good for uh game
design we'll come back to that Neptune
Neptune is a graph a database service in
Amazon so that's kind of out of the
equation and snowball is actually a
storage all right it's it's a transport
medium I would say so that's again out
of the equation so the tie is between
RDS and dynamodb so if we need to talk
about RDS RDS is an a platform as a
service it provides cost efficient
resizable capacity but it's an SQL
database meaning the tables are kind of
strict you know it's good for Banking
and other type of applications but not
really good for anything that has to do
with the gaming so the only option left
is dynamodb again it's the right answer
dynamodb is actually an fast and
flexible nosql database service and it
provides a single digit millisecond
latency at any scale and it's a database
at the same time it's a key Value Store
model database so the right answer is
dynamodb all right let's look at the
next question if you need to perform
real-time monitoring of AWS services and
get actionable insights which service
would you use all right let's list the
services so it talks about real-time
monitoring a firewall manager what does
it provide now firewall manager is not
really a monitor just like the name says
it's a manager it manages multiple
firewalls and AWS guard duty is and
thread detection service it does
monitoring it does continuously monitor
our environment but it monitors for
threats all right only threats now let's
talk about Cloud watch a cloud watch is
a service that helps to track metrics
it's a service that is used to
monitor the environment and give us a
system-wide visibility and also it helps
us to store logs so at the moment it
kind of looks like that could be the
right answer we don't know that yet but
I mean we have one more option left
that's EBS so what's EBS EBS is a block
storage elastic Block store if we
abbreviate EBS it's elastic Block store
so all three of them are easily out of
the question the first one is to manage
second one is to find threats of course
it does monitoring so there's I mean if
there is one relation between Cloud
watch and guard Duty that's monitoring
so easily we can actually find ourselves
slipped towards picking our duty but
know that God duties only for gaining
security inside but not about getting
AWS service inside so cloudwatch is a
service that helps us to get a
system-wide or an AWS wide or an account
wide and it has number of metrics we can
monitor and get a very good Insight of
how a service is performing be it CPU be
it Ram beat Network utilization beat the
connection failures Cloud watch is a
service that helps us perform a
real-time monitoring and get some
actionable insights on the services all
right let's talk about this 33rd
question as a web developer you are
developing an app especially for the
mobile platform all right there is a
mention that this is especially for the
mobile platform so a lot of services
gets filtered out mobile platform right
which of the following lets you add user
sign up sign in and access control to
your web and mobile app quickly and
easily alright so this is all about
signing in to your mobile app so if we
need to read between the lines that's
how we can read sign up or sign in into
a mobile platform all right so we have
like four options here Shield AWS Massey
AWS inspector Amazon Cognito so let's
try to weed out Services which are not
relevant to it so what's AWS Shield AWS
Shield is actually a service that
provides a DDOS mitigation or DDOS
protection denial of service protection
it's a security feature let's talk about
the second option AWS Maxi is again a
security service that uses machine
learning to automatically discover and
classify the data it again talks about
security and this security is all about
encrypting or saving the data does not
come close with signing up an mobile
platform all right let's talk about the
other one AWS inspector now AWS
inspector has something to do with apps
it definitely has something to do with
apps so kind of looks like that as
relevant as of now so it actually helps
with improving the security and
compliance of the apps that we deploy in
the cloud so kind of looks like it could
be because it has to do with apps the
last one Cognito now Cognito is a
service that actually lets the
administrator to have control access
over web and mobile apps and it's a
service that helps us to sign up and
assign in to an mobile and web app so
that very much looks like we found the
answer so cognitos reserves that helps
web app and mobile app for sign up and
signing in and also gives the
administrator to have control over who
has I mean access control over the web
and the mobile app pretty much we found
it so it's cognitive Cognito is a
service that helps us to set up sign up
sign in and have access control over the
users who would be using our mobile and
web app all right how about this
question uh you are an ml engineer or
machine learning engineer who is on the
lookout for a solution that will
discover sensitive information that your
Enterprise stores in AWS and then uses
NLP to classify that data and provide
business related insights which among
the following Services would you choose
so we have a bunch of services that's
going to help us achieve or one of it is
going to help us achieve the about
requirement so it's a service that deals
with machine learning you're a machine
learning engineer who's looking for a
service that will help you to discover
information at your Enterprise store so
we're talking about storage discover
information in store and then classify
the data depending on severity the
sensitivity classify the data so which
service is that so firewall manager just
like the name says it's a manager and
the AWS IAM if we abbreviate it it's a
identity and access manage management so
it's identity and access management
nothing to do with identifying sensitive
data and managing it so the first two is
already out of the equation and then the
AWS is Massey we already had a quick
definition description for AWS Massey
that it's actually a security service
that uses machine learning kind of looks
like it could be it it's a security
service that uses machine learning and
it discovers and classifies the
sensitive information not only that it
does not stop there it goes beyond and
protects the sensitive data AWS Mass it
kind of looks like but we still have one
more option to look at which is cloud
HMS Cloud HMS is also a security service
kind of looks like that could be the
answer as well and it enables us to
generate encryption keys and save the
data so kind of 50 of it it's a security
service it encrypts helps us protect
other data but AWS Maxi is right on spot
it's a machine learning service it helps
us to classify the data and also to
protect the data so the answer for this
question would be AWS messy so hope you
kind of get it how this is going so
first we apply the thumb rule identify
the question that's being asked read
between the lines and then try to find
the service that meets your requirement
then finding the service is by verse
reading out the wrong ones recollect
everything that you've learned about the
service and see how well that matches
with those hints that you have picked up
and if that doesn't match weed that out
then you'll end up with two just two to
decide from at some point and then it
becomes easy for you to decide click on
the question submit it and then move on
to the other question in your interview
alright so how about this one you are a
system administrator in your company
which is running most of its
infrastructure on AWS you are required
to track your users and keep a look on
how your users are being authenticated
all right so this is where the problem
statement starts right you need to keep
track of how your users are being
authenticated and you wish to create and
manage AWS users and use permissions to
allow and deny their access to the AWS
resources right you are to give them
permission number one and then I mean if
we put them in the right order first
giving them permissions and then
tracking their usage let's see which of
the service will help us achieve it IEM
is a service that helps us to looking at
the permissions we can actually predict
whether the user or the group will have
servers or not so that helps us to get a
track of who's able to use who's not
able to use certain servers and all that
stuff so it kind of looks like but we
have other three options left let's look
at AWS firewall manager just like the
name says it's actually a firewall
manager it helps us to manage multiple
firewalls simple as that and shield is a
service it's a service that's used to
protect denial of service or distributed
denial of service an API Gateway is a
service that makes it easy for
developers to create publish maintain
and monitor and secure API so I mean
it's completely on the API side very
Less on user and how you authenticate
your user we can get that by looking at
the name itself right if you abbreviate
it or if we if you try to find a
definition for the name API Gateway you
would get it it has to do with API but
if you upgrade AWS IAM its identity and
access management pretty much meets the
requirement but for the problem
statement about it's AWS identity and
access management that's the right
answer all right let's look at this one
if you want to allocate various private
and public IP address in order to make
them communicate with the internet and
other instances you will use this
service which of the following is this
service so it talks about using public
and private IP address so this service
uses IP address and then this service
helps us to allow love and deny
connections to the internet and to the
other instances so you get the question
is it let's pick the service that helps
us achieve it Route 53 Route 53 is
actually a DNS service right so it's not
a service that's used to allow or deny
no it does not do that VPC VPC uses
public and private IP address yes so
kind of looks like a VPC helps us to
allow I mean the security in VPC the
security group the network access
control list in a VPC the routing table
in a VPC that actually helps us to allow
or deny a connection to a particular IP
address or to a particular service
within the VPC or outside of the VPC so
as of now it kind of looks like it could
be but let's look at the other services
what if if we find a service that
closely matches to the above requirement
than the Amazon VPC Gateway API Gateway
we know that it's a managed service that
makes it easy for developers to create
publish maintain and monitor apis and
secure apis that has completely do with
API not with IP Cloud front we know
about cloudfront that it's a Content
delivery Network and it provides global
distribution of servers where our
content can be cached it could be video
or or bulk Media or anything else they
can be cached locally so users can
easily access them and download them
easily alright so that's cloudfront now
at this point after looking at all four
it looks like VPC is the right answer
and in fact VPC is the right answer VPC
has public IP address VPC he can help us
with the private IP address VPC can be
used to allow deny connection based on
the security group Access Control list
and routing table it has so that's right
answer is VPC all right how about this
one this platform as a service or
platform as a DB service provides us
with the cost efficient and resizable
capacity while automating time-consuming
administrative tasks so this question is
very clear it's a DB service we got to
look for and it's a service that can
provide automating some of the time
consuming tasks it has to be resizable
at the same time so let's talk about
Amazon rational database it's a database
kind of matches the requirement we can
resize it as and when needed
all right looks like it's a fit as of
now it actually automates some of the
time consuming work looks like it's a
fit as of now let's move on to elastic
cache and then try to see if that
matches the definition that we've
figured out about elastic cache it's
actually a caching service it's again an
in-memory data store which helps in
achieving high throughput and low
latency in memory data store so it's not
a full-blown database and it does not
come with any Amazon provisioned
Automation in it for automating any of
the administration tasks now it does not
come up with anything like that yeah we
can resize the capacity as and when
needed but automation it's not there yet
and moreover it's not a database so
that's out of the equation VPC is not a
resizable one you know once we have
designed VPC it's fixed it can be
resized so that's out of the equation
and Amazon Glacier Glacier is a storage
but not a database all right so that's
again of the equation so the tie is kind
of between Amazon rational database
service and Amazon elastic cache because
they both Aid the database service but
elastic cache is not a full-blown
database it actually helps the database
but it's not a full-blaw database so
it's Amazon relational database so
that's the one which is a platform as a
service it's the one which can be
resized it's the one which can be used
to automate the time consuming
administrative tasks all right let's
talk about this one which of the
following is a means for accessing human
researchers or Consultants to help solve
a problem on a contractual or a
temporary basis all right let's read the
question again which of the following is
a means for accessing human researchers
or consultant to help solve problems on
a contractual or a temporary basis it's
like assigning task or hiring AWS
exports for a temporary job so let's try
to find that kind of service in the four
services that are listed Amazon elastic
map reduce map reduce is actually an
framework service that makes it easy and
cost effective to analyze large amount
of data but that has nothing to do with
accessing human researchers all right
let's talk about mechanical terms it's a
web service that provides a human
Workforce that's the definition for it
for example automation is good but not
everything can be automated for
something to qualify for automation it
has to be a repeated task one-time task
can't be automated or the time and money
that you would be spending in automation
is not worth it instead you could have
done it manually so that does not
qualify for Automation and anything that
requires intelligence or anything that's
a special case all right automation can
do reperative tasks automation can do
precise work but it has to be repeated
tasks scenario you know it should have
been there already only then that can be
executed but if it's a new scenario and
it requires appropriate addressing then
it requires human thoughts so we could
hire researchers and Consultants who can
help solve a problem using Amazon
Mechanical Turk the other two are
already out of the equation now Dev pay
is actually a payment system through
Amazon and multi-factor authentication
as it says it's an authentication system
so the right answer is Amazon Mechanical
Turk all right this sounds interesting
let's look at this one this service is
used to make it easy to deploy manage
and scale containerized applications
using kubernetes on AWS which of the
following is this AWS service so it's a
service to deploy manage and scale
containerized applications so it deals
with containers it also should have the
ability to use kubernetes which is a
container orchestration service all
right the first one an Amazon elastic
container service kind of looks like
it's the one the name itself has the
word and the relation we're looking for
elastic
container service so this container
service is an highly scalable high
performance container orchestration
service let's look at the other one AWS
batch it's a service that enables it
professionals to schedule and execute
batch processing I mean the name itself
says that that's meant for batch
processing elastic bean stock that's
another service that helps us to deploy
manage and scale but it helps us with
easy two instances not with
containerized instances so that's again
out of the equation would light still be
a good tie for elastic container service
what's slide sale now light sale is a
service it's called as virtual private
server without a VPC it's called as a
virtual private server it comes with a
predefined in the compute storage
networking capacity it's actually a
server not a container right so at this
point that also becomes out of the
equation so it's Amazon elastic
container service that's the one that
helps us to easily deploy manage scale
container services and it helps us
orchestrate the containers using
kubernetes all right how about this one
all right this service lets us to run
code without provisioning or managing
servers so no servers run code select
the correct service from the below
option all right so no servers but we
should be able to run code Amazon ec2
Auto scaling easy to order scaling ec2
is elastic compute Cloud which is a
server and auto scaling is a service
that helps us to achieve scaling the
server so that's the definition for it
could be that's out of the equation AWS
Lambda now Lambda is a service It's
actually an event driven serverless
Computing platform and Lambda runs code
in response to the event that it
receives and it automatically manages
the compute resource that's required for
that code as long as we have uploaded a
code that's correct and setup events
correctly to map to that code it's going
to run seamlessly so that's about Lambda
it kind of looks like it could be the
answer because Lambda runs code we don't
have to manage servers it manages
service by itself but we can't conclude
as of now we have other two service to
talk about AWS batch all right batch is
service that enables ID professionals to
run batch job we know that and about the
inspector Amazon inspector it's actually
a service that helps us to increase and
identify any security issues and align
our application with compliance well
that's not the requirement of the
question the requirement and the
question was a run code without
provisioning a server and without any
more space for confusion AWS Lambda is a
service or is the service that runs code
without provisioning and managing
Services right the right one would be
AWS Lambda all right so by this we have
come to the end of the first section if
getting your learning started is half
the battle what if you could do that for
free visit scale up by simply learn
click on the link in the description to
know more
I'm glad that we were able to provide
you a second part in AWS interview
questions all right let's get started so
in an environment where there's a lot of
automation infrastructure automation
you'll be posted with this question how
can you add an existing instance to a
new auto scaling group now this is when
you are taking an instance away from the
auto scaling group to troubleshoot to
fix a problem you know to look at logs
or if you have suspended the auto
scaling you know you might need to
re-add that instance to the auto scaling
group only then it's going to take part
in it right only then the auto scaling
is going to count it as part of it it's
not a straight procedure you know when
you remove them you know it doesn't get
automatically re-added I've had worked
with some clients when their developers
were managing their own environment they
had problems adding the instance back to
the auto scaling group you know
irrespective of what they tried the
instance was not getting added to the
auto scaling group and whatever they
fixed that they were provided or
whatever fix that they have provided
were not you know getting encountered in
the auto scaling group so like I said
it's not a straight you know a click
button procedure there are ways we'll
have to do it so how can you add an
existing instance to the auto Skilling
group there are few steps that we need
to follow so the first one would be to
under the ec2 instance console right
under the instance under actions in
specific you know there's an option
called attach to Auto scaling group
right if you have multiple Auto scaling
groups in your account or in the region
that you're working in then you're going
to be posted with the different Auto
scaling groups that you have in your
account let's say you have five Auto
scaling groups for five different
application you know you're going to be
posted with five different or scaling
groups and then you would select the
auto scaling the appropriate Auto
scaling group and attach the instance to
the that particular or scaling group
while adding to the auto scaling group
if you want to change the instance type
you know that's possible as well
sometimes when you want to add the
instance back to the auto scaling group
there would be requirement that you
change the instance type to a better one
to a better family to the better
instance type you could do that at that
time and after that you are or you have
completely added the instance back to
the auto scaling group so it's actually
an seven step up process adding an
instance back to the auto scaling group
in an environment where they're dealing
with migrating the instance or migrating
an application or migrating an instance
migrating and VM into the cloud you know
if the project that you're going to work
with deals with a lot of migrations you
could be posted this question what are
the factors you will consider while
migrating to Amazon web services the
first one is cost is it worth moving the
instance to the cloud given the
additional bills and results features
available in the cloud is this
application going to use all of them is
moving into the cloud beneficial to the
application in the first place you know
beneficial to the users who will be
using the application in the first place
so that's a factor to think of so this
actually includes you know cost of the
infrastructure and the ability to match
the demand and Supply transparency is
this application in high demand you know
is it going to be a big loss if the
application becomes unavailable for some
time so there are few things that needs
to be considered before we move the
application to the cloud and then if the
application does the application needs
to be provisioned immediately is there
an urge is there an urge to provision
the application immediately that's
something that needs to be considered if
the application requires to go online if
the application needs to hit the market
immediately then we would need to move
it to the cloud because in on-premises
procure during buying an infrastructure
buying the bandwidth buying the
switchboard you know buying an instance
you know buying their software so buying
the license related to it it's going to
take time at least like two weeks or so
before you can bring up an server and
launch an application in it right so if
the application cannot wait you know
waiting means you know Workforce
productivity loss is it so we would want
to immediately launch instances and put
application on top of it in those case
if your application is of that type if
there is the urge in making the
application go online as soon as
possible then that's a candidate for
moving to the cloud and if the
application or if the the software or if
the product that you're launching it
requires Hardware it requires an updated
or Hardware all the time that's not
going to be possible in on-premises we
try to deal with Legacy infrastructure
all the time in on-premises but in the
cloud they're constantly upgrading their
hard ways only then they can keep
themselves up going in the market so
they constantly the cloud providers are
constantly updating their hard ways and
if you want to be benefited of your
application wants to be benefited by the
constant upgrading of the Hardwares
making sure the hardware is as latest as
possible the software version the
licensing is as latest as possible then
that's a candidate to be moved to the
cloud and if the application does not
want to go through any risk if the
application is very sensitive to
failures if the application is very much
stacked to the revenue of the company
and you don't want to take a chance in
you know seeing the application fail and
you know seeing the revenue drop then
that's a candidate for moving to the
cloud and business agility you know
moving to the cloud at least half of the
responsibility is now taken care by the
provider in this case it's Amazon at
least half of the responsibility is
taken care by them like if the hardware
fails Amazon make sure that they're
fixing the hardware immediately and uh
notifications you know if something
happens you know there are immediate
notifications available that we can set
it up and make ourselves aware that
something has broken and we can
immediately jump in and fix it so you
see there are the responsibility is now
being shared between Amazon and us so if
you want to get that benefit for your
application for your organization for
the product that you're launching then
it needs to be moved to the cloud so you
can get that benefit from the cloud the
other question you could get asked is
what is RTO and RPO in AWS they are
essentially Disaster Recovery terms when
you're planning for Disaster Recovery
you cannot avoid planning disaster
recovery without talking about RTO and
RPO now what's the RTO what's the RPO in
your environment or how do you define
RTO how you define RPO or some general
questions that get asked RTO is recovery
time objective RTO stands for the
maximum time the company is Will willing
to wait for the recovery to happen or
for the recovery to finish when an
disaster strikes so RTO is in the future
right how much time is it going to take
to fix and bring everything to normal so
that's RTO on the other hand RPO is
recovery Point objective which is the
maximum amount of data loss your company
is willing to accept as measured in time
RPO always refers to the backups the
number of backups the the frequency of
the backups right because when an outage
happens you can always go back to the
latest backup right and if the latest
backup was before 12 hours you have lost
the in between 12 hours of data data
storage right so RPO is the acceptable
amount if the company wants less RPO RPO
is 1R then you should be planning on
taking backups everyone up if RPO is 12
hours then you should be planning on
taking backups every 12 hours so that's
how RPO and RTO you know helps Disaster
Recovery the fourth question you could
get asked is if you would like to
transfer huge amount of data which is
the best option among a snowball
snowball Edge and snowmobile again this
is a question that get asked if the
company is dealing with a lot of data
transfer into the cloud or if the
company is dealing with the migrating
data into the cloud I'm talking about a
huge amount of data data in petabytes
snowball and all of the snowball series
deals with the petabyte sized data
migrations so there are three options
available as if now AWS snowball is an
data transport solution for moving high
volume of data into and out of a
specified AWS region on the other hand
AWS snowball Edge adds additional
Computing functions snowball is simple
storage and movement of data and
snowball Edge has a compute function in
attached to it a snowmobile on the other
hand is an exabyte scale migration
service that allows us to transfer data
up to 100 petabytes that's like 100 000
terabytes so depending on the size of
data that we want to transfer from our
data center to the cloud we can hire we
can rent any of these three services
let's talk about some cloud formation
questions this is a classic question how
is AWS cloud formation different from
AWS elastic bean stock you know from the
surface they both look like the same you
know you don't go through the console
provisioning resources you don't you
know you don't go through CLI and
provision resources both of them
provision resources through click button
right but underneath they are actually
different Services they support they aid
different services so knowing that is
going to help you understand this
question a lot better let's talk about
the difference between them and this is
what you will be explaining to the
interviewer or the panelist so the cloud
formation the cloud formation service
helps you describe and provision all the
infrastructure resources in the cloud
environment on the other hand elastic
bean stock provides an simple
environment to which we can deploy and
run application cloud formation gives us
an infrastructure and the elastic bean
stock gives us an small contained
environment in which we can run our
application and cloud formation supports
the infrastructure needs of many
different types of application like the
Enterprise application the Legacy
applications and any new modern
application that you want to have in the
cloud on the other hand the elastic bean
stock It's a combination of developer
tools they are tools that helps manage
the life cycle of a single application
so cloud formation in short is managing
the infrastructure as a whole an elastic
Beanstalk in short is managing and
running an application in the cloud and
if the company that you're getting hired
is using cloud formation to manage their
infrastructure using or if they're using
infrastructure or any of the
infrastructure as a code Services then
you would definitely face this question
what are the elements of an AWS cloud
formation template so it has a four or
five basic elements right and the
template is in the form of Json or in
yaml format right so it has parameters
it has outputs it has data it has
resources and then the format or the
format version or the file format
version for the cloud formation template
so parameter is nothing but it actually
lets you to specify the type of easy to
instance that you want the type of RDS
that you want all right so ec2 is an
umbrella RDS is an umbrella and
parameters within that ec2 and
parameters within that rdas are the
specific details of the ec2 or the
specific details of the RDS service so
that's what parameter is in a cloud
formation template and then the element
of the cloud formation template is
outputs for example if you want to
Output the name of an S3 bucket that was
created if you want to Output the name
of the ec2 instance if you want to
Output the name of some resources that
have been created instead of looking
into the template instead of you know
navigating through in the console and
finding the name of the resource we can
actually have them outputted in the
result section so we can simply go and
look at all the resources created
through the template in the output
section and that's what output values or
output does in the cloud formation
template and then we have resources
resources are nothing but what Define
find what are the cloud components or
Cloud resources that will be created
through this cloud formation template
now ec2 is a resource RDS is a resource
and S3 bucket is a resource elastic load
balancer is a resource and the NAT
Gateway is a resource VPC is a resource
so you see all these components are the
resources and the resource section in
the cloud formation defines what are the
AWS Cloud resources that will be created
through this cloud formation template
and then we have version a version
actually identifies the capabilities of
the template you know we just need to
make sure that it is of the latest
version type and the latest version is
0909 2010 that's the latest version
number you'll be able to find that on
the top of the cloud formation template
and that version number defines the
capabilities of the cloud formation
template so just need to make sure that
it's the latest all the time still
talking about cloud formation this is an
other classic question what happens when
one of the results in a stack cannot be
created successfully well if the
resource in a stack cannot be created
the cloud formation automatically rolls
back and terminates all the resources
that was created using the cloud
formation template so whatever resources
that were created through the cloud
formation template from the beginning
let's say we have created like 10
resources and the 11th resource is now
failing cloud formation will roll back
and delete all the 10 resources that
were created previously and this is very
useful when the cloud formation cannot
you know go forward cloud formation
cannot create additional resources
because we have reached the elastic IP
limits elastic IP limit per region is
five right and if you have already used
five IPS and a cloud formation is trying
to buy three more IPS you know we've hit
the soft limit till we fix that with
Amazon cloud formation will not be able
to you know launch additional you know
resources and additional IPS so it's
going to cancel and roll back everything
that's true with a missing ec2 Ami as
well if an Ami is included in the
template and but the Ami is not actually
present then cloud formation is going to
search for the Ami and because it's not
present it's going to roll back and
delete all the resources that it created
so that's what cloud formation does it
simply rolls back all the resources that
it created I mean if it sees a failure
it would simply roll back all the
resources that it created and this
feature actually simplifies the system
administration and layout Solutions
built on top of AWS cloud formation so
at any point we know that there are no
orphan resources in the in in our
environment you know because something
did not work or because there was an you
know cloud formation executed some there
are no orphan resources in our account
at any point we can be sure that if
cloud formation is launching a resource
and if it's going to fail and it's going
to come back and delete all the
resources it's created so there are no
orphan resources in our account now
let's talk about some questions in
elastic Block store again if the
environment deals with lot of automation
you could be thrown this question how
can you automate easy to backup using
EBS it's actually a six step process to
automate the ec2 backups we'll need to
write a script to automate the below
steps using AWS API and these are the
steps that should be found in the
scripts first get the list of instances
and then and then the script that we are
writing should be able to connect to AWS
using the API and list the Amazon ABS
volumes that are attached locally to the
instance and then it needs to list the
snapshots of each volume make sure the
snapshots are present and it needs to
assign a retention period for the
snapshot because over time the snapshots
are are going to be invalid right once
you have some 10 latest snapshots any
snapshot that you have taken before that
10 becomes invalid because you have
captured the latest and 10 snapshot
coverage is enough for you and then the
fifth point is to create a snapshot of
each volume create a new snapshot of
each volume and then delete the old
snapshot anytime a new snapshot gets
created the oldest snapshot on the list
needs to go away so we need to include
options we need to include scripts in
our script lines in our script that make
sure that it's deleting the older
snapshots which are older than the
retention period that we are mentioning
another question that you could see in
the interview be it written interview
beat online interview or beat and
telephonic or face-to-face interview is
what's the difference between EBS and
instance store let's talk about EBS
first EBS is kind of permanent storage
the data in it can be restored at a
later point when we save data in EBS the
data lives even after the lifetime of
the ec2 instance for example we can stop
the instance and the data is still going
to be present in EBS we can move the EBS
from one instance to another instance
and the data is simply going to be
present there so ABS is kind of
permanent storage when compared to
instance on the other hand instance
store is a temporary storage and that
storage is actually physically attached
to the host of the machine abs is an
external storage an instant store is
locally attached to the instance or
locally attached to the host of The
Machine we cannot detach an instant
store from one instance and attach it to
another but we can do that with EBS so
that's a big difference one is permanent
data and another one is EBS is permanent
instance store is a volatile data and
instant store with instant store we
won't be able to detach the storage and
attach it to another instance and
another feature of instant store is data
in an instant store is lost if the disk
fails or the instance is stopped or
terminated so instant store is only good
for storing cache data if you want to
store permanent data then we should
think of using EBS and not instant store
while talking about storage on the same
lines this is another classic question
how can you take backups of EFS like EBS
and if you can take backup how do you
take that backup the answer is yes we
can take EFS to EFS backup solution EFS
does not support snapshot like EBS EFS
does not support snapshot snapshot is
not an option for EFS elastic file
system right we can only take backup
from one EFS to another EFS and this
backup solution is to recover from
unintended changes or deletions of the
EFS and this can be automated right any
data that we store in EFS can be
automatically replicated to another EFS
and once this EFS goes down or gets
deleted or data gets deleted or you know
the whole EFS is for some reason
interrupted or deleted we can recover
the data from we can use the other EFS
and bring the application to consistency
and to achieve this it's not an One Step
configuration it's a cycle there are
series of steps that's involved before
we can achieve EFS to EFS backup the
first thing is to sign in to the AWS
Management console and under EFS or
click on EFS to EFS restore button from
the services list and from there we can
use the region selector in the console
navigation bar to select the actual
region in which we want to work on and
from there ensure that we have selected
the right template you know some of the
templates would be you know EFS to EFS
backup granular backups incremental
backups right so there are some
templates the kind of backups that you
want to take do you want to take
granular do you want to take increment
backups stuff like that and then create
a name to that solution the kind of
backup that we have created and finally
review all the configurations that you
have done and click on Save and from
that point onwards the data is going to
be copied and from that point onwards
any additional data that you put is
going to copy it and replicate it now
you have an EFS to EFS backup this is
another classic question in companies
which deals with a data management there
are easy options to create snapshots but
deleting snapshots is not always and you
know click button or a single step
configuration so you might be facing a
question like how do you Auto delete old
snapshots and the procedure is like this
now as best practice we will take
snapshots of EBS volume to S3 all
snapshots get stored in S3 we know that
now and we can use AWS Ops automator to
automatically handle all snapshots the
Ops automator service it allows us to
create copy delete EBS snapshots so
there are cloud formation templates
available for AWS Ops automator and this
automator template will scan the
environment and it would take snapshots
it would you know copy the snapshot from
one region to another region if you want
I know if you're setting up a Dr
environment and not only that based on
the retention period that we create it's
going to delete the snapshots which are
older than the retention period so life
or managing snapshot is made lot easier
because of this Ops automator cloud
formation template moving into questions
in elastic load balancer this again
could be an a question in the interview
what are the different types of load
balances in AWS and what's their use
case what's the difference between them
and as of now as we speak there are
three types of load balances which are
available in AWS the first one being
application load balancer just like the
name says the application load balancer
works on the application layer and deals
with the HTTP and https requests and it
also supports path based routing for
example simplylearn.com
some web page simplylearn.com another
website so it's going to direct the path
based on the slash value that you give
in the URL so that's path based routing
so it supports that and not only that it
can support Port based a colon 8080
colon 8081 or colon 8090 you know based
on that Port also it can take a routing
decision and that's what application
load balancer does on the other hand we
have Network load balancer and the
network load balancer makes routing
decisions at the transport level it's
faster because it has very less thing to
work on it works on Lower OSI layer it
works on a lower layer so it has very
less information to work with than
compared with application layers so
comparatively it's a lot faster and it
handles millions of requests per second
and after the load balancer receives the
connection it selects a Target group for
the default rule using the flow hash
routing algorithm it does simple routing
right it does not do path based or Port
based routing it does simple routing and
because of it it's faster and then we
have classic load balancer which is kind
of expiring as we speak Amazon is
discouraging people using classic load
balancer but there are companies which
are still using classic load balancer
they are the ones over the first one to
step into Amazon when classic load
balancer was the first load balancer or
the only load balancer available at that
point so it supports http https TCP SSL
protocol and it has a fixed relationship
between a load balance report and the
container Port so initially we only have
classic load balancer and then after
some point Amazon said instead of having
one load balancer address all type of
traffic we're going to have a two load
balances called as the child from the
classic to load balancer and one is
going to specifically address the
application requirement and one is going
to specifically address the network
requirement and let's call it as
application load balancer and network
load balancer so that's how now we have
two different load balances talking
about load balance another classic
question could be what are the different
uses of the various load balancer in AWS
elastic or load balancing there are
three types of load balancer we just
spoke about it application load balancer
is used if we need a flexible
application management and TLS
termination and network load balancer if
we require Extreme Performance and the
load balancing should happen on based on
static IPS for the application station
and classic load balancer is an old load
balancer which is for people who are
still running their environment from
easy to Classic Network now this is an
older version of VPC or this is what was
present before VPC was created easy to
Classic network is what was present
before ec2 was created so they are the
three types and they are the use cases
of it let's talk about some of this
security related questions you would
face in the interview when talking about
security and firewall and AWS we cannot
avoid discussion talking about Waf web
application firewall and you would
definitely see yourself in this
situation where you've been asked how
can you use AWS Waf in monitoring your
AWS applications Waf or web application
firewall protects our web application
from common web exploits and Waf helps
us control which traffic Source your
application should be allowed or a Blog
which traffic from certain Source now
which source or which traffic from a
certain Source should be allowed or
blocked your application with Waf we can
also create custom rules that blocks
common attack patterns you know if it is
a banking application it has a certain
type of attacks and if it is simple data
management data storage application it
has I mean content management
application it has a separate type of
attack So based on the application type
we can identify a pattern and create
rules that would actually block that
attack based on the rule that we create
and Waf can be used for three cases you
know the first one is allow all requests
and then block all requests and count
all requests for a new policy so it's
also an monitoring and Management
Service which actually counts all the
policies or counts all the requests that
matches a particular policy that we
create and some of the characteristics
we can mention in AWS web or the origin
IPS and the strings that appear in the
request test we can allow block based on
Origin IP allow block based on strings
that appear in the request we can allow
block or count based on the origin
country length of the request yeah we
can block and count the presence of
malicious scripts in an connection you
know we can count the request headers or
we can allow block a certain request
header and we can count the presence of
a malicious SQL code in a connection
that we get and that want to reach our
application still talking about security
what are the different AWS IM categories
we can control using AWS IAM we can do
the following one is create and manage
IM users and once the user database gets
bigger and bigger we can create and
manage them in groups and in IM we can
use it to manage the security
credentials kind of setting the
complexity of the password you know
setting additional authentications you
know like MFA and and you know rotating
the passwords now resetting the password
there are few things we could do with
the IAM and finally we can create
policies that actually grants access to
AWS services and resources another
question you will see is what are the
policies that you can set for your users
password so some of the policies that we
can set for the user password is the
minimum length or you know the
complexity of the password by at least
having one number or one special
characters in the password so that's one
and then the requirement of a specific
character types including you know
uppercase lowercase number and
non-alphabetic characters so it becomes
very hard for somebody else to guess
what the password would be and and try
to hack them so we can set the length of
the password we can set the complexity
in the password and then we can set an
automatic expiration of the password so
after a certain time the user is forced
to create a new password so the password
is not still old and easy to guess in
the environment and we can also set
settings like the user should contact
the admin I mean when the password is
about to expire so you know you can get
a hold of how the user is setting their
password is it having good complexity in
it is it meeting company standards or
there are few things that we can control
and set for the users when the users are
setting or recreating the password
another question that could be posted in
an interview so to understand your
understanding of IEM is what's the
difference between an IM role and an IM
user let's talk about IM user let's
touch small and then go big or let's
start simple and then talk about the
complex one the IM user has a permanent
long term credential and it's used to
interact directly with AWS services and
on the other hand IEM role is an IM
entity that defines a set of permissions
for making AWS service request so IM
user is an permanent credential and role
are temporary credentials and the IM
user has full access to all AWS IEM
functionalities and with role trusted
entities such as IM users application or
AWS Services assume are the role so when
an IM user is given an a permission you
know it sticks within the IEM user but
with roles we can give permissions to
Applications we can give permissions to
users in the same account in a different
account a corporate ID we can give
permissions to ec2 S3 RDS VPC and lot
more role is wide and IM user is is not
so wide you know it's very constrained
only for that IM user let's talk about
manage policies in AWS manage policies
there are two types now customer managed
and Amazon managed so manage policies
are IM resources that Express
permissions using the IAM policy
language and we can create policies edit
them manage them manage them separately
from the IM user group and roles which
they are attached to so they are
something that we can do to managed
policies if it is customer managed and
we can now update policy in one place
and the permissions automatically extend
to all the attached entries so I can
have like three services four Services
point to a particular policy and if I
edit that particular policy it's going
to reflect on those three or four
services so anything that I allow is
going to be allowed for those four
Services anything that I denied is going
to be denied for the four Services
imagine what would be without the IM
managed policy will have to go and
specifically allow deny on those
different instances four or five times
depending on the number of instances
that we have so like I said there are
two types of manage policies one is
managed by us which is customer managed
policies and then the other is managed
by AWS which is AWS managed policy this
question can you give an example of an
IM policy and a policy summary this is
actually to test how well-versed are you
with the AWS console the answer to that
question is look at the following policy
this policy is used to Grant access to
add update and delete objects from a
specific folder now in this case name of
the folder is example folder and it's
present in a bucket called example
bucket so this is an IAM policy on the
other hand the policy summary is a list
of access level resource and conditions
for each service defined in a policy so
IM policy is all about one particular
resource and the policy summary is all
about multiple resources with IM policy
it was only talking about S3 bucket and
one particular S3 bucket here it talks
about cloud formation template Cloud
watch logs ec2 to elastic bean stock
Services summary summary of resources
and the permissions and policies
attached to them that's what policy
summary is all about another question
could be like this what's the use case
of IAM and how does IM help your
business two important or primary work
of IM is to help us manage IAM users and
their access it provides a secure access
to multiple users to their appropriate
AWS resources so that's one it does and
the second thing it does is manage
access for Federated users Federated
users or non-iam users and through IAM
we can actually allow and provide a
secured access to resources in our AWS
account to our employees without the IM
user no they could be authenticated
using the active directory they could be
authenticated using the Facebook
credential Google credential Amazon
credential and a couple of other
credentials the party identity
management right so we could actually
trust them and we could give them access
to our account based on the trust
relationship that we have built with the
other identity of systems all right so
two things one is manage users and their
access for manage IAM user and their
access in our AWS environment and second
is manage access for Federated users who
are non-im users and more importantly IM
is a free service and with that will
only be charged for the use of the
resources not for the IM username and
password that we create all right let's
now talk about some of the questions in
Route 53 one classic question that could
be asked in an interview is what is the
difference between latency based routing
and Geo DNS or Geo based DNS routing now
the jio based DNS routing takes routing
decisions on the basis of the geographic
location of the request and on the other
hand the latency based routing utilizes
latency measurements between networks
and data centers now latency based
routing is used where you want to give
your customers the lowest latency as
possible so that's when we would use
latency based routing and on the other
hand a geo-based routing is when we want
to direct customers to different
websites based on the country they are
browsing from you know you could have
you know two different or three
different websites for the same URL you
know take Amazon the shopping website
for example when we go to amazon.com
from in the US it directs us to the US
webpage where the products are different
the currency is different right and the
flag and and couple of other
advertisements that shows up are
different and when we go to amazon.com
from India it gets directed to the
amazon.com Indian site where again the
currency the product and the
advertisements they're all different
right so depending on the country
they're trying to browse if you want to
direct customers to two or three
different websites we would use a
geo-based routing another use case of
geobase routing is if you have a
compliance that you should handle all
the DNS requests sorry if you should
handle all the requests you know from a
country within the country then you
would do geo based routing now you
wouldn't direct the customer to a server
which is in another country all right
you would direct the customer to a
server which is very local to them
that's another use case of jio based
routing and like I said for latency
based routing the whole goal or aim is
to achieve minimum end user latency if
you are hired for the architect role and
if that requires working law lot on the
DNS then you could be posted with this
question what is the difference between
domain and a hosted Zone a domain is
actually a collection of data describing
a self-contained administrative and
Technical unit on the internet right so
for example you know simplylearn.com is
actually a domain on the other hand
hosted zone is actually an container
that holds information about how you
want to Route traffic on the internet to
a specific domain for example
lms.simplylearn.com is an hosted Zone
whereas simplylearn.com is an domain so
in other words in hosted Zone you would
see the domain name plus and a prefix to
it LMS is a prefix here FTP is a prefix
mail.simplieron.com is a prefix so
that's how you would see a prefix in
hosted zones another question from
another classic question from Route 53
would be how does Amazon Route 53
provide High availability T and low
latency the way Amazon Route 53 provides
High availability and low latency is by
globally distributed DNS service Amazon
is a global Service and they have DNA
Services globally any customer doing a
query from different parts of the world
they get to reach an DNS server which is
very local to them and that's how it
provides low latency now this is not
true with all the DNS providers there
are DNS providers who are very local to
a country who are very local to a
continent so they don't they generally
don't provide low latency service right
it's always high latency it's low
latency for local users but anybody
browsing from a different country or a
different continent it's going to be
high latency for them but that's not
again true with Amazon Amazon is a
globally distributed DNS provider it has
DNS servers Global wide and like I said
it has optimal locations it has got a
global Service or in other words it has
got so servers around the globe
different parts in the globe and that's
how they are able to provide High
availability and because it's not
running on just one server but on many
servers they provide High availability
and low latency if the environment that
you're going to work on is going to take
a lot of configuration backups
environmental backups then you can
expect questions in AWS config a classic
question would be how does AWS config
work along with AWS cloudtrail AWS
cloudtrail actually records user API
activity on the account and you know any
HTTP https access or any any sort of
access you know that's made to the cloud
environment that's recorded in the cloud
trail in other words any APA calls the
time is recorded the type of call is
recorded and what was the response given
was it a failure was it successful they
also get recorded in cloudtrail it's
actually a log it actually records the
active T in your Cloud environment on
the other hand config is an a point in
time configuration details of your
resources for example at a given point
what are all the resources that were
present in my environment what are all
the resources or what are the
configuration in those resources at a
given point they get captured in AWS
config all right so with that
information you can always answer the
question what did my AWS resource look
like at a given point in time that
question gets answered when we use AWS
config on the other hand with cloudtrail
you can answer the question I mean by
looking at the cloud trail or with the
help of cloudtrail you can easily answer
the question who made an APA call to
modify this resource that's answered by
cloudflail and with cloudtrail we can
detect if a security group was
incorrectly configured and who did that
configuration let's say there happened
to be in downtime and you want to
identify let's say there happened to be
a downtime and you want to identify who
made that change in the environment you
can simply look at cloudtrail and find
out who made the change and if you want
to look at how the environment looks
like before the change you can always
look at AWS config can AWS configure or
AWS config aggregate data across
different AWS accounts yes it can now
this question is actually to test
whether you have used AWS config or not
I know some of the services are very
local is it some of these services are
availability Zone specific some of them
are Regional specific and some of them
are Global Services in Amazon and though
some of the services are region Services
you still can do some changes you know
add some configuration to it and collect
Regional data in it for example S3 is a
regional service but still you can
collect logs from all other regions into
an S3 bucket in one particular region
that's possible and cloud trail is and
Cloud watch is an regional service but
still you can with some changes to it
with some adding permissions to it you
can always monitor the cloud watch that
belongs to Cloud watch logs that belongs
to other regions you know they're not
Global by default but you can do some
changes and make it Global similarly AWS
config is a service that's a
region-based service but still you can
make it act globally we can aggregate
data across a different region and
different accounts in an AWS config and
deliver the updates from different
accounts to one S3 bucket and can access
it from there AWS config also works or
integrates seamlessly with SNS topic so
you know anytime there is a change
anytime a new data gets collected you
can always notify yourself or notify a
group of people about the new log or the
new config or new edit that happened in
the environment let's look at some of
the database questions you know database
should be running on reserved instances
so whether you know that fact or or not
the interviewer wants to understand how
well you know that fact by asking this
question how are reserved instances
different from on-demand DB instances
reserved instances and on-demand
instances are exactly the same when it
comes to their function but they only
differ based on how they are built
reserved instances are purchased for one
year or three year reservation and in
return we get a very low per hour
pricing because we're paying up front
it's generally said that reserved
incidence is 75 percentage cheaper than
on-demand instance and Amazon gives you
that benefit because you know you're
committing for one year and sometimes
you're paying in advance for the whole
year on the other hand on-demand
instances are built on an hourly hourly
price talking about Auto scaling how
will you understand the different types
of Auto scaling the interviewer might
ask this question which type of scale
would you recommend for RDS and why the
two types of scaling as you would know
now vertical and horizontal and in
vertical scaling we can vertically scale
up the master database with a couple of
clicks all right so that's vertical
scaling vertical scaling is keeping the
same node and making it bigger and
bigger if previously it was running on
T2 micro now we would like to run it on
M3 two times large instance previously
it had one virtual CPU one gigabit now
it's gonna have eight virtual CPU and 30
gigabit of ram so that's vertical
scaling on the other hand the horizontal
scaling is adding more nodes to it
previously it was running on one VM now
it's going to run on 2 3 10 VMS right
that's horizontal scaling so database
can only be scaled vertically and there
are 18 different types of instances we
can resize our rds2 right so this is
true for RDS MySQL postgres SQL mariadb
Oracle Microsoft SQL servers there are
18 type of instances we can vertically
scale up to on the other hand horizontal
scaling are good for replicas so they
are read-only replicas we're not going
to touch the master database we're not
going to touch the primary database but
I can do horizontal scaling only with
Amazon Aurora and I can add additional
read replicas I can add up to 15 Read
replicas for Amazon Aurora and up to
five read replicas for RDS MySQL
postgres SQL and mariadb RDS instances
and when we add replica we are
horizontally scaling adding more nodes
right I read only nodes so that's
horizontal scaling so how do you really
decide between vertical and horizontal
scaling if you're looking into increase
the storage and the processing capacity
we'll have to do a vertical scaling if
you are looking at increasing the
performance or of the read heavy
database we need to be looking for
horizontal scaling or we need to be
implementing horizontal scaling in our
environment still talking about database
this is another good question you can
expect in the interview what is the
maintenance window and Amazon RDS will
your DB instance be available during the
maintenance event all right so this is
really to test how well you have
understood the SLA how well you have
understood the Amazon rdas the failover
mechanism of Amazon rdas stuff like that
so RDS maintenance window it lets you
decide when ADB instance modification a
database engine upgrades or software
patching has to occur and you you
actually get to decide should it happen
at 12 in the night or should it happen
at afternoon should it happen early in
the morning should it happen in the
evening you actually get to decide an
automatic scheduling by Amazon is done
only for patches that are security and
durability relay it sometimes Amazon
takes down and does automatic scheduling
if you know if there is a need for a
patch update that deals with security
and durability and by default the
maintenance window is is for 30 minutes
and the important point is the DB
instance will be available during that
event because you're going to have
primary and secondary right so when that
upgrade happens Amazon would shift the
connection to the secondary do the
upgrade and then switch back to the
primary another classic question would
be what are the consistency models in
dynamodb in dynamodb there is eventual
consistency read this eventual
consistency model it actually maximizes
your read throughput and the best part
with eventual consistency is all copies
of data reach consistency within a
second and sometimes when you write and
when you're you know trying to read
immediately chances that you you would
still be reading the old data that's
eventual consistency on the other hand
there is another consistency model
called the strong consistency or
strongly consistent read where there is
going to be a delay in writing the data
you know making sure the data is written
in all places but it guarantees one
thing that is once you have done a write
and then you're trying to do a read it's
going to make sure that it's going to
show you the updated data not the old
data now you can be guaranteed of it
that it is going to show the updated
data and not the old data that's
strongly consistent still talking about
database talking about nosql dynamodb or
nosql database which is dynamodb and
Amazon you could be asked this question
what kind of query functionality does
dynamodb support dynamodb supports get
and put operation dynamodb supports or
dynamodb provides a flexible querying by
letting you query on non-primary key
attributes using Global secondary index
and local secondary indexes our primary
key can be either a single attribute
partition key or a composite partition
sort key in other words a dynamodb
indexes a composite partition sort key
as a partition key element and a sort
key element and by holding the partition
key you know when doing a search or when
doing a query by holding the partition
key element constant we can search
across the sort key element to retrieve
the other items in that table and at the
composite partition sort key should be a
combination of user ID partition and a
timestamp so that's what the composite
partition sort key is made of let's look
at some of the multiple choice questions
you know sometimes some companies would
have an written test or an McQ type
online test before they call you for the
first level or before they call you for
the second level so these are some
classical questions that companies asked
or companies ask in their multiple
choice online questions let's look at
this question as a developer using this
pay-per-view service you can send store
and receive messages between software
components which of the following is
being referred here let's look at it and
we have AWS step functions Amazon mq
Amazon simple Q service Amazon simple
notification service let's read the
question again as a developer using this
pay-per-view service so the service that
we are looking for is a pay-per-view
service you can send store and retrieve
messages between two software components
kind of like a queue there so what would
be the right answer it would be Amazon
simple Q service now Amazon simple queue
service is the one that's used to
decouple at the environment it breaks
the tight coupling and then it
introduces decoupling in that
environment by providing a queue or by
inserting a queue between two software
components let's look at this other
question if you would like to host a
real-time audio and video conferencing
application on AWS right it's an audio
and video conferencing application on
AWS this service provides you with a
secure and easy to use application what
is this service let's look at the
options they are Amazon chime Amazon
workspace Amazon mq Amazon appstream all
right you might tend to look at Amazon
appstream because it's real time and
video conference but it's actually for a
different purpose it's actually Amazon
chime that lets you create chat and
create a chat board and then collaborate
with the security of the AWS services so
it lets you do the audio it's lets you
do the video conference all supported by
AWS security features it's actually
Amazon China let's look at this question
as your company's AWS solution architect
you are in charge of Designing thousands
of individual jobs which are similar
which of the following service best
serves your requirement AWS easy to
order scaling AWS snowball AWS fargate
AWS batch let's read the question again
as your company's AWS solution architect
you are in charge of Designing thousands
of individual jobs which are similar it
looks like it's batch service let's look
at the other options as well AWS
snowball is actually an storage
Transport service ec2 auto scaling is
you know in introducing scalability and
elasticity in the environment and AWS
far gate is container services AWS batch
is the one is being referred here that
actually runs thousands of individual
jobs which are similar AWS batch it's
the right answer let's look at the other
one you are a machine learning engineer
and you're looking for a service that
helps you build and train machine
learning models in AWS which among the
following are we referring to so we have
Amazon sagemaker and AWS deep lens
Amazon comprehend AWS device form let's
read the question again you are a
machine learning engineer and you're
looking for a service that helps you
build and train machine learning models
in AWS which among the following are
referred here the answer is Sage maker
it provides every developer and data
scientist with the ability to build
train and deploy machine learning models
quickly that's what sagemaker does now
for you to be familiar with you know the
products I would recommend you to you
know simply go through the product
description you know there's one page
available in Amazon that explains all
the products a quick neat and simple and
that really helps you to be very
familiar with you know what the product
is all about and what it is capable of
you know is it the DB service is it a
machine learning service or is it a
monitoring service is it a developer
service stuff like that so get that
information get that details before you
attend an interview and that should
really help to answer or face such
questions with a great confidence so the
answer is Amazon Sage because that's the
one that provides developers and a data
scientists the ability to build the
train and deploy machine learning models
quickly as possible all right let's look
at this one let's say that you are
working for your company's ID team and
you are designated to adjust the
capacity of the AWS resource based on
the incoming application and network
traffic how do you do it so what's the
service that's actually helps us to
adjust the capacity of the AWS resource
based on the incoming application let's
look at it Amazon VPC Amazon IAM Amazon
inspector Amazon elastic load balancing
Amazon VPC is a networking service
Amazon IAM is an username password
authentication Amazon inspector is a
service that actually does security
audit in our environment and Amazon
elastic load balancer is a service that
helps in scalability that's in one way
you know indirectly that helps in
increasing the availability of the
application right and monitoring it
monitoring you know how much requests
are coming in through the elastic load
balancer we can actually adjust the
environment that's running behind it so
the answer is going to be Amazon elastic
load balancer all right let's look at
this question this cross-platform video
game development engine that supports PC
Xbox PlayStation IOS and Android
platforms allows developers to build and
host their games on Amazon's service so
we have Amazon game lift Amazon green
grass Amazon Lumberyard Amazon Sumerian
let's read the question again this
cross-platform video game development
engine that supports PC Xbox PlayStation
IOS and Android platforms allows
developers to build and host their games
on Amazon servers the answer is Amazon
lumber yard this lumber yard is an free
a triple a gaming engine deeply
integrated with AWS and and twitch with
full source this lumba yard provides a
growing set of tools that helps you
create an highest game quality
applications and they connect to a lot
of games and vast compute and storage in
the cloud so it's that service they are
referring to let's look at this question
you are the project manager of your
company's Cloud architect team you are
required to visualize understand and
manage your AWS cost and usage over time
which of the following service will be
the best fit for this we have AWS
budgets we have AWS cost Explorer we
have Amazon workmail we have Amazon
connect and the answer is going to be
cost Explorer now cost Explorer is an
option you need the Amazon console that
helps you to visualize and understand
and even manage the AWS cost over time
who's spending more who's spending less
and what is the trend what is the
projected cost for the coming month all
these can be visualized in AWS cost
Explorer let's look at this this
question you are a chief Cloud architect
at your company and how can you
automatically Monitor and adjust
Computer Resources to ensure maximum
performance and efficiency of all
scalable resources so we have a cloud
formation as a service we have AWS
Aurora as a solution we have AWS Auto
scaling and Amazon API Gateway let's
read the question again you're the chief
Cloud architect at your company how can
you automatically Monitor and adjust
Computer Resources how can you
automatically Monitor and adjust
Computer Resources to ensure maximum
performance and efficiency of all
scalable resources this is an easy
question to answer the answer is auto
scaling right that's a basic service and
solution architect course is it auto
scaling is the service that helps us to
easily adjust Monitor and ensure the
maximum performance and efficiency of
all scalable resources it does that by
automatically scaling the environment to
handle the inputs let's look at this
question as a database administer later
you will use a service that is used to
set up and manage databases such as
MySQL mayodb and postgres SQL which
service are we referring to Amazon
Aurora Amazon elastic cache AWS RDS AWS
database migration service Amazon Aurora
is Amazon's flavor of the RDS service
and elastic cache is is the caching
service provided by Amazon they are not
full-fledged database and database
migration service just like the name
says it helps to migrate the database
from on-premises to the cloud and from
one a database flavor to another
database flavor Amazon RDS is the
service is the console is the service is
the umbrella service that helps us to
set up manage databases like MySQL
Murray DB and postgres SQL it's Amazon
RTS let's look at this last question a
part of your marketing work requires you
to push messages to onto Google Facebook
Windows and Apple through apis or AWS
Management console you will use the
following service so the options are AWS
cloudtrail AWS config Amazon chime AWS
simple notification service all right it
says a part of your marketing work
requires you to push messages it's
dealing with pushing messages to Google
Facebook Windows and Apple through apis
or AWS Management console you will use
the following service it's simple
notification service simple notification
service is a message pushing service and
sqs is pulling similarly SNS is pushing
right here it talks about a pushing
system that pushes messages to Google
Facebook Windows and Apple through API
and it's going to be a simple
notification system or a simple
notification service
hope you learned something new today if
you have any doubts about the topics
mentioned in the video please let us
know in the comment section and we will
get back to you with Solutions
subscribe to our channel for more
informative videos like this thank you
for watching
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos turn it up and get certified
click here
foreign